The job,
real good experience.
Well all day we don't know what
everyone's panicky wet.
What do I do?
I'm suddenly faced with adversity and my
botox is running out so my head is
actually able to squint.
Just order an uber.
Before the rain hits you,
you'll be okay.
Then you just watched somebody else
freak out and you think about it like he
starts thinking that.
How much has this guy been screened?
You know,
was it,
was I supposed to be getting picked up
by a lyft driver and the uber driver
intercepted the signal or did.
Did Uber know about all that shit?
We're uber employees were calling
apparently.
There's like one guy was doing it like
one guy was like pushing it.
They were calling like Uber Rides or
Uber was calling lyft rides and then
like just canceling the Gig really
fucking up.
Their bitch is fucking up their business
prank calls,
like fake fake orders for cars and shit.
Like.
Which is really.
I mean I know it's not.
The whole company does not want to use a
company when you hear shit like
maybe that's what it takes this.
Somebody took the Glen Gary,
Glen Ross
first scene to heart.
Just doing that at every level of Uber.
Yeah.
You want coffee,
you got to be a fucking closer coffee's
for closers.
I,
I just wish,
you know,
I mean it seems like Uber was doing so
well like it.
I just wished there would be a company
like that that would turn out to be
super cool.
You know?
I always wished that about every company
that I like,
you know,
like Oh,
wouldn't it be nice if they're super
cool?
Yeah.
Like secretly all of Walmart's money was
going to some kind of charity instead of
just.
Walmart is always going to be a problem
and I don't mean that in a good way or a
bad way.
It means just like whenever you have a
big giant thing,
you have a problem on both sides.
You know,
like one problem is people go,
well,
you know,
Walmart comes into town and it kills all
the small businesses and are we really?
That grows that like saving a dollar
here and five cents there is worth us
going to some giant box where some
people are in it that we don't know or
are we going to go to our local place
where we have like a relationship with
the people that own it.
It's like this small connection,
like you're directly connected to these
people's lives.
I think the issue at least where I fuck
up as a consumer is you drive by and
let's say you need a new tire for your
car and you know you don't really care
about your car that much.
It's like a Corolla or whatever that has
the cheapest tires in town.
So like ideologically I don't really
care who my tire replacement person is
or their wellbeing or their quality of
life.
I just want the cheapest tire.
See I don't.
I get that.
And then like it spills over into other
areas of your life where you're like,
well I want healthy groceries,
but what if Walmart can give me the
cheapest fucking lettuce?
Then maybe I just don't care.
I send a lot of people.
I think eventually just buy everything
that way.
Right?
Yeah.
Well it can definitely go that way.
I mean if you're a smart consumer,
if that's all you're worried about and
you're just worried about numbers,
but I think that there's companies that
you just don't have a relationship with.
You don't feel bad about that.
Like,
well,
I don't have a relationship with whole
foods.
I don't know them.
You know,
I go there.
The folks are all nice that worked
there,
but I know they're just working there.
You know the guys where you get the Kale
Salad from.
Super Cool.
Say Hi to say hi to the butcher Chit
Chat with the people at the cash
register.
Like,
yeah,
everybody's friendly.
But I know that their employees,
you know what I'm saying?
Like I don't feel connected to giving
them my money,
but like this restaurant that I go to
all the time and the folks that own it,
they've owned it for like 30 years and
they're just the nicest,
friendliest people.
They're just really cool to talk to.
Like every time I talked to them,
like the guys from Greece and he's
always telling me about like the
difference between the way people behave
there and behave here and just I get
into these cool conversations with him.
He's a very bright well read guy and
just an interesting guy.
So I love going there and giving them my
money.
But if I go to like applebee's,
I don't fucking know anybody.
Yeah.
The 16 year old hostess,
she's not going to be there next week.
It'll be somebody else.
Yeah,
I mean I'll be friendly to them for
sure.
You know,
it's nice if you get the same waitress
again.
Oh Hey.
How you doing was no culture there
though,
corporation.
Well that's,
that's what we,
we miss in like losing those little
small businesses,
you know.
But the first small business owner,
man,
it's a fucking grind.
It's hard to do.
I mean you have to,
you have to really be selling something
somebody wants.
Like there's a,
there's a fucking starbucks down the
street here and next to the starbucks
there's a shoe dealer,
like a not a shoe dealer shoe repairman.
I'm like,
dude,
like how many fucking people are getting
their shoes repaired?
I mean,
is there some like death of a salesman
type still out there need to get their
shoes polished before an interview?
I mean,
I guess it's a,
I guess if you have enough people in an
area that is going to be enough.
People wear heels or falling off and I
mean maybe I'm naive,
but every time I go by that place
there's fucking nobody in it.
I'm like,
who the hell's kitchen?
Their shoes fixed.
I would dress up like Jay gatsby one day
and just go in there and pull up in that
big yellow convertible that he had.
Then Leonardo Dicaprio had.
I was super torn on that movie.
I was torn on it in two ways.
One,
it was like so surreal.
Everything was so crazy.
Like the way it was filmed,
it was so obvious like you were watching
a dream or something,
you know?
It was the special effects.
Like when they were at the party and the
glitter was flying and everybody's
dancing.
It's so over the top.
The way he was driving over the top.
It was almost hard to accept it as like
a real story,
like watching a story about real humans.
I think that goes back to the book
itself.
Like I remember liking it a lot in high
school and college and thinking like
this is what life was like back in the
day in New York.
And then you get older and you're like,
that's not life at all.
That's just some frivolous bullshit that
somebody thought up.
It was like a,
you know,
romance,
a romance narrative
within the 19 twenties.
It has no application of modern life at
all.
It's just a fucking fantasy.
What's a sad ending with phantom?
Well,
there is something,
I'm sure much more than there is now to
someone who has a completely fabricated
existence.
There's something we all think is
amazing about that.
Like someone who could just fabricate
their life and like how long can they
pull it off?
Like it's a great plot engine,
which he's good at.
Dicaprio is like the master of being the
uh,
was that a movie he was in?
Where use the con artists kind of Wolf
of Wall Street or the wolf of Wall
Street.
And then I'm thinking of um,
catch me if you can.
Oh,
you,
that's right.
And then really remember that one.
He's a bad motherfucker.
I mean he doesn't get as much credit
because he's beautiful and he's a,
you know what I'm saying?
He's beautiful and he's kind of a pussy.
That's always the case for us.
Yeah,
well him especially I'm in,
I think he's one of the greatest actors
ever.
But like,
he's such a beautiful man and he's
silly.
He's obviously so privileged.
People look at him like this fucking
guy.
He's.
Yeah,
he's pretty good actor.
Listen,
if that guy was ugly,
he would be saluted.
He would be mean.
Forget what Steve Buschemi gets kind of
loves DBA.
Shimmy gets here.
We'll get that times a thousand.
If he was ugly,
if he looked like Steve Buschemi,
God damn capital with the toast of the
town,
he needs a couple scars.
No,
he's too pretty.
Even if he gets a couple of scars,
people like good.
You know,
they,
like,
he's lived his life,
a beautiful,
wealthy,
super talented actor.
That's too much for some people,
you know,
I know people who don't take them
seriously.
Like I've had conversations with,
you know,
quote unquote actor folks who are really
brutal,
really brutal.
I was watched,
watched at the beginning of move of a
movie,
a really good movie with this,
uh,
this friend of mine and uh,
this actor walks by and goes a man.
His career really fell off after this
movie talking about.
It was Jurassic Park,
the,
the first one.
And uh,
there's the dude who,
uh,
he was in event horizon,
Sam Neill,
Sam Neill.
Exactly.
The dude's like,
hey,
his career really fell off after this
movie.
Like,
shut the fuck up and just watch the
movie.
Jesus Christ does it have to be about
that.
But they even real actory actor times
just like praise performances,
you know,
oh my God.
Jeff Goldbloom was amazing in that film.
He's quirky looking at enough.
He allow them to be amazing in a film.
But Leonardo Dicaprio,
Goddamn beautiful man.
Perfect bone structure.
Just as handsome as fuck.
Beautiful Hair,
the perfect Ville and Django.
Oh well that's why you get to see his
range.
How good he really is.
Weight when he flips a switch and goes
evil towards the end of the movie,
you know like Yo,
like you buy it.
Like he's not like there's certain dudes
who scream and yell and a movie and it
almost ruins the movie because it makes
me want to smack them.
Like if somebody was screaming and
yelling at you that you know,
you fake fuck this,
you're not even angry.
Look at Shit is this,
I'm going to smack you.
But when he's screaming and yelling in
that movie,
you're like,
oh,
we're at def con nine here.
We're about to get nuclear.
Like Shit.
Someone's going to get shot.
Like this is like a death run.
Like there's this something horrible.
Is gonna happen at the end of this
conversation?
Like you got that from in the wolf,
the wolf of Wall Street to and it's
gacked out of his mind.
Yeah.
There's like a.
like he really believed that he could go
off the rails and fucking set off a
suitcase nuke or something stupid.
You know,
he's gone
but too beautiful.
Too beautiful for Hollywood.
Sure.
Definitely Django.
They made him look fucked up his teeth.
Yeah,
they did a good job.
That's what people looked like back
then.
They didn't have fucking caps.
Yeah.
And they uh,
smoke from a pipe all day.
This,
I know a dude who got,
um,
he got,
I guess their veneers.
He got teeth put on over his teeth.
Yeah.
They just.
Jamie's fucking yell at his teeth.
Yes ma'am.
Nobody had pretty teeth back then,
man.
But he turned psycho towards the end.
Right?
Let's see here.
Um,
was I saying,
oh,
I know this dude.
You know,
they have those veneer things and they
make it look like you're wearing a
mouthpiece.
Look at,
make sure lipstick out more.
This guy is fucking lip.
Stick out more now it's like,
he's like,
he's wearing a very thin mouthpiece.
What if he doesn't wear it?
It's just yellow teeth.
He can't not wear it.
Chip away your teeth.
They chip away the surface of your teeth
and they put this new surface.
All of your permanent.
Okay.
Yeah,
and it's like a veneer.
It's like a like this would if you took
a really thin slice of this wood and put
it over some plastic bullshit and
pretended it was oak.
So that's what they're doing.
They have this perfect white ceramic
thing.
I guess it's like a ceramic or some may
be.
It may be something like
some plastic veneer.
Yeah,
but what like what is it made out of
though?
It's like billiard ball type shit.
Phenolic hookup.
How you talk.
You get it done.
Well this guy did this guys are too big.
I mean I don't know what's going on.
I mean if he just decided to get bigger
teeth or something like that.
But I'm looking at him talking and it's
like he's wearing like a little bit of a
mouthpiece.
I've been honest.
This weird kick lately where I'm
fascinated by people altering their
image like radically.
I got onto with Renee Zellweger,
like I saw that renee,
Renee Zellweger thing.
That is like the textbook case of
somebody.
Yeah.
Then is and Jennifer Gray?
No,
not chatter for Greg.
Is that her from dirty dancing?
What was her name?
Is that right?
Jennifer Gray.
She was really pretty,
but she had a big nose.
Then she got her nose fixed.
I now,
I'm not sure if it works.
Is it Jennifer Gray?
Yeah,
she was really pretty,
but she,
you know,
she had a Jewish looking knows that
European hump thing going on,
which is just character,
you know,
for sure.
Whatever.
Right.
Plus it disappears if you're looking
dead at anything.
Yeah.
Well she was cute and then she became,
I guess,
you know,
she likes it better,
but it's,
she's a different person,
that's for sure.
So anyway,
I got on this kick lately where I
started looking at all these,
uh,
different procedures that people have
done and uh,
I watched a nose job yesterday.
Somebody sent me a nose job on twitter
of this,
uh,
this woman getting her nose fixed.
I tweeted it.
You can see it on my twitter page,
but it's a long video of the entire
process.
It's sped up a bit,
but holy shit,
is it brutal?
Like the nose,
well,
you know,
I had my nose cleaned out like I had my
nose,
a deviated septum repair to has smashed
Septum and it was blocking off most of
my ability to breathe out of my
nostrils,
but this,
this is,
this was way more involved because they
had to actually chip away her bone.
They peeled her nose back like a banana
and then chipped away the bone to make
the nose smaller and then put it all
together again.
Isn't it amazing the lengths people go
to to do something that nobody cares
about any way?
Well,
some people do care though.
See,
that's the thing.
You know,
you can't say that.
Some people don't look better once you
fix their fucked up nose because.
Well,
Renee Zellweger,
nobody would have cared if she had just
aged and looked somewhat like she used
to look.
Not that you don't have the right to
change your appearance,
but it was just that that sudden shock.
That kind of surprised people.
Well,
imagine this.
Okay,
you,
you're a young man and you make your
living off of your mind.
Okay?
You make your living off of your
commentary,
your ability to notice things,
podcasting,
things along those lines.
I'm much older than you.
I'm 47 years old,
but my brain doesn't work any
differently than when I was young.
My body is slowly but surely starting to
work less good.
Like I get injured more easily.
Like I still work out pretty hard,
but when I get injured like I fucked my
elbow up a couple months ago in this
bitch just won't get better.
You know what I mean?
So those kinds of things.
But I'm not a professional athlete.
If I was,
I would be freaking out.
I'd be freaking out if I was a
professional talker,
if my brain started to slowly slow down
and my brain started not able to form
sentences or not being able to recognize
and objective behavior problems or you
know,
confusion of what the topic is I'm
discussing.
If those types of things started
happening on a regular basis and someone
came along and said,
hey,
we can give you this drug.
You know,
it's gonna make you 70 percent better.
Yeah.
It's like,
you know,
you're getting old,
we're going to shoot your forehead up
with botulism and it's going to freeze
the whole thing so you can't,
you can't look frown and then it'll
relax.
It will make you look a little better.
You're like,
okay,
okay.
And then everybody's like,
what's wrong with your fucking.
But to her,
she's like my forehead's lynee anymore.
Yeah.
The acting career has been extended
maybe,
but maybe people are just going to get
weirded out by you,
you know?
Did you see that Dutchess who's worth
like some an godly amount of money,
but she's had like insane amounts of
plastic surgery and she's just taken ill
just pull.
If you buy better view,
pull up Dutchess plastic surgery
disaster you see here.
But this poor lady,
when she was young,
she was very pretty and obviously that
meant a lot to her.
If there was a big part of who she was,
not just a part of who she was,
but like most of her world probably for
a lot of beautiful women.
It's like you're,
you're born with the greatest lottery
ticket ever.
Like everywhere you go,
people are just tripping over themselves
to get to you,
to be nice to you,
to get close to you,
to give you things,
and it's really just because of the
dimensions of your face and your body.
It's incredible and you have to be quite
a piece of shit to fuck that up.
Like to like to get it so that men don't
want to talk to you.
Even though you're perfectly designed,
you have to be like really annoying,
you know,
you have to be like really mean are
really selfish or were guys like,
I don't care how hot she is out of here,
you know,
most,
there's almost always going to be a
suitor.
That's a good picture of her by the way.
And I'm not kidding.
There's a before and after of her.
That's really quite brutal.
Yeah.
That's what she used to look like.
But that's like as she was getting
older,
that was before she really hit it hard.
I'll just go ahead and find it.
But um,
where was,
I was on a part of the money but she's
unhappy.
So we were talking about good looks
about how like how valuable that is.
It's a massive thing.
So imagine if you're a woman and your
entire self worth is derived off your
looks,
which is possible.
It sounds sad.
People are like,
well,
what do we put it?
Sexist fucking things that say men.
Women don't think like that.
But listen,
let's be realistic.
Men think like that.
There's some men that think like that.
There she is.
There's some men that think like that
and there's some good.
Yeah,
there's some people that are fucking
beautiful and those people,
they do have that Willy Wonka golden
ticket and a lot of times it's just
being born that way just to roll the
dice.
So if you got that lottery ticket and
you're watching it slip away for some
people,
that's a very,
very,
very tough pill to swallow.
They gotta read some Alan Watts slipping
away for everybody and we're all kind of
a continuous thing.
Yeah.
But then they see these young girls is
20 year old girl laughing and giggling
like cube bitch,
just angry,
you know?
Do you think there's more envy between
women and there is between men because
guys don't have a lot of.
We don't have like generational envy
adult really.
Um,
I don't know,
but this is what I definitely think.
I definitely think there's zero value in
wondering who's got it worse.
Men Or women,
you know?
Who Do you think it's worse for a man to
feel jealous or a woman to feel Joe's?
Um,
I think it's definitely not worrying.
Worth worrying about.
Got It.
Worse in that situation.
Like the men.
I think the men woman thing is way safer
to be a guy in some respects.
You know,
you don't have to worry about women,
but you still have to worry about men.
But other than that,
there's benefits to both sides.
Clearly,
you know,
it's,
it's really entirely who you are and how
you look at it.
There's women who you talked to them.
The last thing they would ever want to
do is be a fucking man.
Like,
are you kidding?
You guys are morons.
I'm going to be one of these apes just
running around trying to stick my tube
steak into people.
And shoot Goo all the time and I'm lying
to them constantly to try to get to that
position pulleys and blind and myself
about who I am to appeal more sexually
attractive.
You see New Jersey is considering a bill
that would make it or it would make it.
It would make it sexual assault.
Yeah.
Form of sexual assault to lie about how
much money you make,
which is really interesting,
but not just lie about money lie about
anything.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
The idea is that using deception in
order to get sex,
that you're a liar and you've,
you frauded someone.
But man.
Okay.
So then if that's the case,
then we're,
we're putting,
we're making sex like a value.
Well we're,
we're making sex.
Like by saying that you're,
you're essentially condoning a form of
prostitution because if that's the case
then is it a felony or whatever the fuck
type of charge they're calling it.
What kind of charge are they calling it?
What fence?
Whatever level of fences.
Why is it not a felony or a crime of a
similar order?
If I decide to lie to you to become your
friend and make you give me a massage.
No.
Right,
no.
Then it's not because then you know you
weren't sexually assaulted.
It's like the idea of sex and the idea.
This person was absolutely willing to
have sex with that person,
but only because that person didn't
exactly tell the truth.
Well,
if you're,
if you get like friends with someone and
have them stay over your house and here,
here man,
borrow my car because you think the guy
has a lot of money.
It turns out he's totally fucking broke
and a con artists.
Is that a felony?
I bet it's not.
I bet if he goes to court and your
honor,
the guy let me borrow his car.
Did you?
Mr Siemen let him borrow your car.
I thought he was the Duke of fucking
Duchess of whatever.
You know?
Yeah.
Let him borrow my car.
Well,
you should have checked on that case to
semest.
Yeah,
but if you get fucked,
if you let that guy fuck your face,
then people are going to go,
hey,
you got rapes on you guys.
You got the bad end of the stick for
sure.
The shorter end of the stick a maybe
not.
I mean look,
people shouldn't lie,
but I don't know if you can make laws
like that,
so it's such a slippery slope because if
a guy is dressed well,
a night club on a Saturday night and
he's got a nice watch on,
is he not misrepresenting himself?
Is that sexual assault?
If he takes the girl back?
Yeah know I guess he's supposed to dress
in a fucking garbage man outfit because
that's his income level or can you
actually look good on a weekend and I'm
kind of like playing a little thought
experiment here,
but just because that's,
you know,
that's a very valid point.
It does seem like a slippery slope,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a very valid point.
How about if someone with a fucking
counterfeit watch on.
Yeah,
I mean that's a big thing with some
guys.
They buy fake watches up and down Canal
Street rolodex rollback.
They're all over the place.
Yeah.
And they're pretty good like some of the
copies because now they have computers
that can scan like it used to be when if
you bought like a fake rolex,
she had to hire someone to create the
plans and have it.
I can just three d print that shit.
Probably like 99 point nine percent the
same thing.
It's really similar.
I mean they can.
The good ones actually take a rolex and
they literally copy every piece of it.
I don't know.
Power efficient.
It is.
I don't.
I mean half of them probably break.
I mean who the fuck knows what kind of
quality control they have.
But if you're looking at it,
if you don't know any better,
you like,
that's a rolex.
This guy's got money.
That's like a $5,000
watch.
Meanwhile no lives with.
His mom bought the watch for 50 bucks.
I bought it on craigslist with bitcoin.
Is that guy,
is he a fraud as he should he go to jail
for that?
How's that work?
He's only a fraud to himself.
I think that one of the big things about
an expensive waste of money.
Watch this,
you can look down and be like,
I earned this.
So if you're looking down at something
that like reasserts that you're full of
Shit,
then what do you like?
What kind of energy are you putting out
there?
You know?
Well that's the thing that I'd rather
pay $100 for a watch.
It's actually like a real fossil or
real,
you know,
real time Max.
Then a fake rolex,
but a fake rolex.
It looks exactly like a rolex and worked
perfectly.
The sound like a fake Ferrari,
you know,
you get a fake Ferrari on the highway,
like this fucking thing's terrible.
No,
it's a watch.
I mean,
it doesn't do a lot.
Just tells you what fucking time it is.
Not only that,
the reality is those mechanical watches,
they're beautiful and everything like
that.
It's kind of cool.
I like the idea behind it that like a
craftsman takes this watch and
constructs it and all the wheels and
gears and everything are all sinked up.
I think that's absolutely fascinating,
but one of those fucking quartz watches
works way better.
Those courts power watches,
those fucking things are never wrong.
There they stay like their time stays
perfect forever.
I have expensive rolex that the UFC gave
me a watch that I would buy,
but it's a beautiful watch and that
fucker's wrong.
Like every two months I got to like back
it up five minutes and I'm not
exaggerating.
It's like every two months it's five
minutes fast.
It's like,
you know,
thousands of dollars for this fucking
thing.
If you.
It's old technology.
It's actually a.
it's kind of a fetish for,
for rich men.
Yeah.
See,
this is like this watch doesn't cost
much and it glows in the dark and you
can go under water with it.
Yeah.
It's never wrong.
It doesn't.
It doesn't get tired and then when it
does,
it's like a fucking two year lifespan
on the battery.
You put a new battery in your good.
Well not 30 years with the Apple Watch
coming out.
Anyone who doesn't have an apple watch
is going to be by default,
a hipster.
So you'll be like,
oh,
okay.
You're old fashioned.
You have the vintage watch on.
I don't buy that.
I don't think so.
Nope.
Too problematic.
It's a bunch of problems with the watch.
First of all,
no one wants to fucking be completely
connected to your shit all the time like
that.
It's one thing about having a phone but
constantly staring at your watch,
like your Dick Tracy and getting text
messages on your watch.
That shit's stupid.
Especially because you're.
You have to have your phone as well.
Like you already have your phone.
Like what do you.
Why do you,
why you want to look at your watch and
get the weather.
So on your fucking phone.
It's right there.
What do we do?
You need it to be on everything.
How about you put it across your Dick
and like a big neon sign in your
underwear.
So when you peek and get the weather,
this is stupid.
Like we're getting ridiculous.
Like how many more things do we need?
I didn't.
I didn't realize you needed to have the
phone on you.
If that's the case,
it makes it a little less cool.
Well,
I'm sure you can use it without the
phone,
but it doesn't have cellular
functionality it might have for the
cellular function because I mean maybe
it's just like an appendage for an
iphone.
We don't really need that.
Well,
I mean it's essentially a small little
computer on its own.
It carries mp3s.
You can do a lot of things with it.
It does work as a watch,
you know,
I'm sure if you load the weather and all
that stuff up on it,
it probably stays on,
but I'm pretty sure it syncs up to your
watch this last week.
This bracelet,
this is a concept,
but supposedly they show it working.
I'll show you the video.
This brace,
this.
They're showing two things here,
but this bracelet as well I was talking
about.
This is a video playing out of a
bracelet on your wrist and at the
working iphone or screen touchscreen.
Oh my God.
And do it underwater.
Wow.
Whoa.
See,
we're getting too crazy.
But it's also a concept to.
They're asking for money.
They said they needed like a million
dollars to get it working.
Somebody better check the tech on that.
Maybe you had to pumping dump.
I'm not invested in money in anything
that's not already there looking cool.
It's going to be just give us a million
dollars.
Yeah.
I don't get that.
People I'm going to get involved in the
ground floor and no,
don't do that.
That's the case with,
uh,
with bitcoin and all coins really,
like there are,
aside from Bitcoin,
there are thousands of other coins and
they suck people in because it's one of
those things where,
um,
uh,
your mind goes,
this could be the next bitcoin,
but statistically it's not going to be,
but it could be.
And so you put money into it and most of
those things turned out to be bullshit.
But there are a couple that are
promising so.
Well,
it was funny talking to Andreas
Antonopoulos yesterday who's a really
fucking interesting dude.
I'm glad we.
I'm glad we have him on our side,
the human race since,
because he would be really dangerous in
the hands of the military,
industrial nsa type side of things.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm sure they have guys like him that
level of intelligence,
but when he was talking about Bitcoin,
one of the things that he was talking
about was how
it's important to recognize that this is
not something that you're going to do
and get rich off of like you.
If you're getting involved in this.
You get involved in this because you
believe in it and that's essentially
what's going on right now.
And he likes that.
You know,
it's like the,
you know,
the people that are investing all their
money,
it's very likely you're gonna lose your
but on long run,
on the other hand it's also likely or
not likely,
it's possible you can make an
astronomical amount because I'm Peter
diamandis talks about this.
There's a youtube lecture people can
look up called exponential thinking and
he's the guy who started the x prize
foundation and I realized that part of
it is probably just he wants to give
really bad ass lectures,
but I think that what he's saying is
actually true.
And that's that once you get any
technology and make it completely
digital,
it has to follow Moore's law to some
extent where you get that doubling of
sophistication every year to 18 months
and uh,
if you kind of ignore the price itself
that's been happening with Bitcoin,
like the sophistication of it is roughly
doubling every year in terms of services
offered on top of it and things you can
do with it.
And if you follow that out to its
logical extreme,
um,
it eventually has to be worth a lot more
than it's worth now because nobody's
really using it.
You know,
it's like a couple million people using
it that's less than one percent,
well,
less than one percent of financial
transactions.
If you get up to maybe like five or 10
percent,
which is totally reasonable,
I think that number has to be much,
much larger.
Yeah.
For 10 percent sign out of the realm of
possibility,
especially when you consider they're
starting to use it on paypal.
I mean,
as soon as you can use it on paypal,
people are like,
Ooh,
that's pretty easy.
If I could just go with bitcoin instead
of dollars and you could start,
you know,
he set up a bitcoin account connected to
your paper towels are buying things.
Well,
the thing was some of the remaining
critics and the media of Bitcoin were
saying,
you know,
it's great technology,
but it's not there yet because it's not
ready for the masses.
And increasingly that's no longer a
valid argument because there are a few
companies that have built stuff on top
of Bitcoin,
which is kind of what people had been
saying would happen.
Right?
And these services are so mainstream
friendly that you take one look at it
and you're like,
oh,
I get it.
Like the change tip thing.
Uh,
I had been doing stuff with them,
like playing with their tipping thing.
You,
you've been getting a lot.
I don't know if you've been ignoring
them,
but it's actually real money.
People are sending you and somebody
said,
hey,
great podcast.
Here's a coffee.
How do you know where it is?
It goes on your twitter.
Uh,
they,
they're very smart about it.
It integrates with your twitter account
or your reddit account or google plus
and it's like a just masses friendly I
can say to you like,
Hey,
enjoy the video yesterday,
here's a beer and it sends you like $3
worth of Bitcoin does all the shit on
the back end.
So all you need to know is what your
twitter password is and you can collect
your money.
Yeah,
but what if you don't have an account?
As long as you have a twitter account,
they'll like allow you to log in and
collected.
Oh,
how bizarre.
It's really well done.
It's a cool idea to a bunch of those.
Well I didn't know what they were
saying.
Just like ignored it.
Yeah.
No,
those are
for real.
They're not like phishing attempt.
So those are strangers sending you money
because they like your podcast,
which right now is still probably,
you know,
a very small percentage of listeners.
But what about when everybody has one of
these things in their wallets and
whenever they hear a podcast they like,
they can just spontaneously send you
fifty cents like that multiplied by a
thousand people or 200,000
people.
You can tell advertisers to get fucked
within a couple of years.
You know,
that's true.
But you run into the risk of running
into people that.
One of the things that I like about the
fact that the podcast is free.
So like when if people complain or if
there's something they don't like or
something they want different price was
right.
Yeah.
Like let's do this is how I'm doing it.
No,
I don't want to hear it.
You should just try.
Why don't you make it an hour?
Why don't you just stop,
listen,
stop,
stop.
I'm doing what I'm doing.
If you don't like it,
that's cool.
But if they're paying for it,
then they'll,
they'll be much more likely in that.
It's not most people,
but it's like selecting out the random
problem people.
It's like most people,
you allow them to buy you a drink and
everything's cool,
you know?
But there's that rare person,
you know,
I was in Vegas recently and this guy
didn't even bias drink.
I was sitting with my friend Justin,
and it was after UFC we're just catching
up,
having a couple drinks,
shooting the shit.
There's this fucking guy and his wife
and they were hammered next to us.
They wouldn't leave us alone,
they just wouldn't,
just wouldn't stop.
And the guy was just dumb.
He kept interrupting with the questions
and it was annoying everyone around
them.
And then finally the dude chimes in and
I go,
come on,
man.
I go,
we're just trying to have a
conversation.
I mean,
I,
I can't keep talking to you about this,
you know,
you keep interrupting in the middle of
everybody talking.
He goes,
hey man,
I bought you a fucking drink that
somebody who needs an express hit of lsd
or something so they can see like just
the little tiny picture of what an
asshole they're being.
And then when he was just an idiot,
it was just really dumb.
But he won.
Meanwhile,
he didn't buy me a drink.
He did.
And I go,
no,
you didn't.
I go,
first of all,
I'm not drinking so you haven't bought
me a drink,
and my friend Justin paid the tab tab,
the thing he was lording over you.
He didn't even do,
but in his mind he was like,
he's probably bought drinks for people
before,
so he decided this is where I was
fucking and I bought them at drank.
I bought you a god to me.
He was just so drunk and dumb and just
that those people are out there and so
if those people are paying for your
podcast,
you know,
if you're asking for donations,
please donate to my pay pal button and
then you get these twitters.
I was going to donate to like hurt your
ignorant rant on Ferguson.
Did sister line in the sand,
David Seaman,
Ferguson is where we separate the heroes
from the zeroes that people are going to
change this culture.
There's a lot of people like super
pumped up to start a revolution.
They're walking into fucking traitor.
Joe's clapping their hands saying you
can't stop the revolution.
Have you seen this?
This fucking videos of these morons?
And it's usually like
menopausal women,
um,
dudes with aimless,
shiftless minds,
you know,
people that there's something wrong with
them.
They're out there walking through
supermarkets yelling at people.
People are just trying to,
you can't stop the revolution.
It's like,
what revolution is this?
The revolution that interrupts shopping
with shitty singing,
the Revolution of affordable yogurt and
fresh fruits,
vintages,
doing nothing but making a lot of energy
and sound by doing it.
Like,
I get that you're upset about police
brutality.
I get that you're upset about the way
this country is going.
I get the.
But going through trader Joe's,
clapping your hands is in fixing a
fucking thing because just going to
alienate people to whatever dumb idea
you have.
Yeah.
Uh,
there was a woman in Venice beach who
came up to me recently and asked me to
sign our petition to run for president.
She's going to run.
Yeah,
I know.
I was Kinda like,
well,
don't you maybe you want to start with
like a youtube channel or something.
Like,
who the fuck are you?
You know,
you can't just leap right to president.
And she had a few signatures and she was
so serious about it and I was like,
well,
what's the platform?
And she's like,
we're going to eliminate homelessness in
Venice beach.
And I was thinking like,
that's not really a national platform,
you know,
you're going to become president and be
like,
we have to address the five homeless
people right here.
So,
um,
my point though is I think that people
think that they have to change something
and they have to do something because
they can see all the problems around
them.
And for some people that's,
let's go to a protest or let's,
let's run for office or let's,
you know,
let's just start a petition.
No matter how ridiculous it sounds.
And the sad reality is,
revolution is silent nowadays.
Like the people who are online buying
bitcoin and developing these other coins
are creating more of a revolution than
anybody in the trader Joe's on a
Tuesday.
Well,
I think what they're trying to do is
raise awareness.
I guess what,
who the fuck isn't aware?
But this ferguson ruling went down to
this riots and Missouri who's unaware
that you don't,
you don't have to walk through Pasadena
yelling at people.
Like those people were aware.
Well I was tweeting out stuff about,
um,
I was like,
why do black people distrust law
enforcement so much?
It's not just this one case like some of
the people on Fox News or making it seem
like this is happening in a vacuum and
it's that black people are really
discriminated against when you look at
the percentages of,
of drug charges and stuff,
even after decriminalization occurs in
states like Massachusetts,
blacks continue to get arrested at
disproportionately high rates.
So you know,
there's some kind of racism happening
there.
Well,
or you know,
there's two things for sure.
There's racism definitely.
And definitely it makes it more
difficult for cops.
You know,
if you are dealing with like say if
you're a good cop and you know,
you're dealing with a community that's
been totally ostracized because there's
been a bunch of cops that came before
you that profile a black people that
pick them out to harass them,
forcing a couple of laws that just
shouldn't exist anymore.
Like it's weird me that here in the
great God fearing state of California,
I can smoke weed and I consider it to be
an antidepressant for me.
And I do it legally.
You know,
I'm a law abiding citizen.
I have the medical marijuana card.
You just go a couple hours away and
suddenly you're like cool hand Luke,
uh,
to get the same exact thing.
Like now you're on the wrong side of the
law and that's the case in half the
country.
Like we have this weird limbo thing.
We're half the states,
have it half don't.
Oh,
you mean just the marijuana?
Yeah,
just the marijuana.
And like as like a white journalists,
like I'm probably not going to be the
one who's singled out.
But if you're a dis,
uh,
um,
like any kind of disadvantaged minority,
your chances of being busted for
something like that is way higher.
And then the cost,
just the cost to your,
um,
your career and everything,
it can take years to get that off your
record.
So that's a real thing that is somewhat
a happening along racial lines.
Yeah.
I'm the fucking see about this.
Uh,
uh,
that's a minor.
I mean,
that's a least like a physical thing
that you can,
you could say like,
oh,
it's a thing.
It's marijuana.
This is what,
you know,
they're getting arrested for.
Did you hear about this fucking guy that
uh,
the cops stopped the man for walking
with his hands in his pocket.
No,
it sounds like a guy in Michigan who was
doing nothing wrong and they both pull
out their cell phones and they film each
other.
So there's a two phones standoff between
the cop and the guy and it's the most
ridiculous shit ever.
I mean,
this fucking guy just has his hands in
his pocket.
That's it.
It's just a black guy who happens to
have his hands in his pockets and the
cop starts questioning him and the guy
pulls his phone out of the cop,
pulls his phone out.
They're both recording each other at the
same time.
It's like,
what are we doing?
That guy's not doing anything wrong.
Let him go.
He's not doing shit.
Okay?
He's walking with his hands in his
pocket.
He pulled out his phone.
He's filming.
You're filming him.
You're wasting my fucking money and I'm
going crazy seeing this,
so please let that fucking guy walk.
He's not committing any crimes,
but walking was fucking hands in his
pocket.
Everybody,
everywhere you look might be doing
something that you can't see that's
illegal.
It doesn't mean you get to knock on
everybody's fucking door and going,
I didn't even see inside your house.
What are you doing in there?
You don't get to do that Douche bag and
when a guy's walking down the street
with his hands in his pockets,
he might as well be alone in his home
until you see something actually
suspicious,
like he's reaching into his hand,
like he's pulling out a fucking gun out
of his inside of his jacket.
If you don't see that,
then shut the fuck up because you just
seen a guy walking and you're allowed to
put your hands in your pocket to stay
warm.
Don't have to like walk everywhere with
our hands up.
Is that our new thing,
David Seaman?
We have to walk with her fingers moving.
So we know that there's no razor blades
in between them.
We most certainly do not.
I think that,
um,
it's a real issue where I think that
people,
a lot of people or status in the same
way that,
um,
the few hundred years ago people were
really a blindly adherent to the church,
said anything.
Even if the church says something
completely ridiculous,
like the church said,
Galileo is wrong.
So we have to keep them under house
arrest.
And today the state,
this similarly kind of opaque
organization says Julian Assange is
wrong.
We have to keep him under house arrest
in his thing and that embassy,
it's Kinda the same thing,
like you have somebody who's just the
thought criminal saying things that you
don't like,
but there are actually some extent,
completely fucking true,
at least in the case of Galileo in the
case of some of the surveillance stuff.
Uh,
so how,
how,
how different is it really?
And you have people ruining lives over
marijuana possession in a state like
Missouri that's a little behind the
times in that respect.
And you go,
well,
what,
what gives you this right to do that?
You're just like an agent of the church
ruining people's lives over accusations
of witchcraft.
It's similarly nonscientific,
you know,
there's no scientific basis for this
stuff.
There's no public safety basis.
Well,
I think once,
once the time has gone and passed and
there's been enough space to reflect,
people are going to look back of
marijuana legalization.
Very similar to the way they looked at
like putting people in jail for being a
witch.
Oh,
for sure.
I think every age,
every age has some kind of evil that for
whatever reason,
the people living through it just don't
really see how big a deal it is.
And that one before was segregation and
now I believe it to be,
um,
prohibition and not just of drugs,
economic prohibition.
Like why are these little companies
playing with Bitcoin,
concerned about the government going
after them for money laundering and
stuff.
It's ridiculous,
you know,
like they're trying to play with these
laws that were designed 40 years ago and
the technologies are totally different
now.
Well,
one of the things that prohibition does
similar to censorship,
that's insidious.
One of the more insidious aspects of it
is not just that they,
um,
you know,
you have a difference,
a differing opinion as to what should,
and should not be acceptable behavior,
whether it's saying certain words or
using certain drugs.
But it becomes a thing where another
person has control over you and it's
preventing you from doing something that
you want to do.
And when people prevent people from
doing things they want to do,
it builds up resentment and it causes
conflict.
And it fucks up a lot of harmonious
relationships.
It's very difficult to deal with the
idea of one person having ultimate power
over you,
especially for something like marijuana
or,
you know,
saying certain words.
If you go to court,
okay,
you're in court and you know,
the guy passes some sort of a ruling on
you and you're like,
fuck you,
your honor.
That's bullshit.
They can throw you in jail for longer
because you said,
fuck you,
your honor.
Just some guy.
Contempt of court.
Yeah.
Some guy who by the way it's been proven
there.
Just people.
All right.
It's not like this is like a hood that
the judges.
Oh human,
no,
everyone's a fucking person.
So you've just got people there and you
so can't say fuck
you to that guy if he does something
unbelievably wrong.
And meanwhile has been proven in
countless cases of judges being arrested
for fraud.
Judges being arrested for corruption,
masturbating in robes,
thing in Pennsylvania was pretty bad.
He was sending all these kids to some
kid corrections facility.
The worst.
He was getting paid.
Yeah.
He was getting paid to do that.
And he's in jail now for like 35 years
and that's not enough.
That's like a dickens novel that's awful
to treat kids like that and just taking
kids away from their parents and having
them locked up and he was profiting off
of it.
Deal where they would pay him that.
That's a judge,
that's the judge.
It's a person that's this.
It all comes back to the drug war and
prohibition because uh,
a lot of stuff is just too complicated.
You can't say that it's purely good or
evil and it's gray areas.
But as far as I'm concerned,
the private prison industry,
which is a real thing is as close to
pure evil as you can get.
You have people who are using all the
tools of capitalism which are
significant tools and they're using it
not to,
you know,
build us a better phone next year or to
cure some new kinds of cancer.
They're using it to keep people in cages
for exploring their own minds and a
trafficking and things that are just
natural herbs.
I mean,
that's,
to me,
it's close to evil as you can get.
Well,
it's a machine that
when have you,
when you got a big business like that,
whether you're a big business is Walmart
or target,
you know when,
when they get in trouble for trying to
change regulations and laws in order to
allow them to make more money in certain
ways,
that might not be legal right now.
People look at them like,
oh,
they're terrible.
Oh,
they're evil.
They're just trying to stay alive.
There are machine and the machine that
generates money.
When you get a million people involved
in that machine and you,
you,
you essentially have a million pieces
and these pieces run this organism,
this organism call it target or call it
a name.
Any one of them.
Once they become a machine there,
they want to continue to extract money
in any way they can.
Once they have that process going,
they want to continue and if it just
means arresting more people and locking
them up in their houses because the
house make money every for every person
in that house,
you get x amount of dollars a year.
The more people you get,
the more money we get.
The more laws on the books and more
people will get to the more laws that
were on the books,
the more money we'll will our,
our organism will get.
And every one of these corporations,
every one of them,
whether it's fucking,
whether it's target or whether it's fill
in the blank,
you know,
starbucks,
they all want to grow every year.
They want to grow,
they want to get bigger and bigger and
bigger.
No one wants to taper off.
Hey,
we've been doing good for about 10 years
guys.
Um,
my house is pretty much paid off.
Like let's just taper off.
I don't need more money.
I don't need a boat.
Come on man.
If I had a boat out of a fixed the boat
and cleaned the boat,
fuck that.
Nobody does that.
So when you deal with a company like
target or you deal with a company like a
Bob's prisons or whatever the fuck is,
it's the same thing.
You're allowing someone to make money
doing.
Well,
I think,
I think you nailed the heart of the
issue,
which is these institutions are there to
extract money and if we can get a better
form of money then even though we're
still gonna,
have people doing human things which
involves making as much money as
possible.
If they're actually using more fair
money,
then we can track that flow and it can
be done in a more fair way.
Like I'm pretty convinced that a lot of
the shit we see in terms of
militarization and all the military
industrial complex and whatnot,
it's because of the way our financial
system works,
that we have the government to go back
to comparing government to the church
from a few hundred years ago.
He had this organization that is beyond
the average person's understanding and
they're the ones in charge of money and
it's very unscientific and it's kind of
mysterious.
And it seems like that money always
loops back around and goes to these
kinds of organizations like,
um,
like,
uh,
companies that lobby for prison
contracts and not to the individual.
You know,
there's,
there's an intrinsic problem there.
And,
uh,
based on what I've researched,
I really think that this whole currency
revolution is going to fix a lot of that
so we're still going to have shitty
problems,
but it's going to be a lot harder in 10
years to be a Booz Allen Hamilton or a,
a Lockheed Martin or whatever,
and do the creepy stuff.
You'll still be able to do the good
stuff,
but the creepier sides are going to be
just really hard to justify because that
money is going to have to come from
somewhere.
Like in the same way that those tipping
services are taking off a.
every citizen is going to have some say
over where their money actually goes.
And that sounds like it's very
futuristic still.
But it's going to happen I think faster
than people realize because it's
happening.
You know?
Well,
if that's the case,
it's going to be a weird world to see
companies,
corporations become accountable and
started having to address and adjust.
And if you force them to be accountable,
they're essentially comprised at people.
If the people at the top end of the
spectrum or not just being forced to act
ethically but are encouraged to and are
empowered by doing so,
like they get to feel good about the
fact that look,
everybody can make a living and not
raped the world.
It is possible.
I mean just the idea that capitalism has
to be this monster that doesn't give a
fuck about anything but money.
That's only because we've allowed it to
be that we haven't liked strained it,
constrained it with ethics and morals
and essentially that's the case with
human beings.
Psychopaths come from.
When you think murderers and fucking
warlords come from.
I don't think it's a human being,
but hold on.
That's a human being that hasn't been
constrained,
right?
I mean that's what it is.
It's a human being that hasn't been
like,
hey,
you need to develop along the way a
series a,
a set of ethics,
morals.
We become a good person or you could
become a good company as well,
or you can kind of bribed your way
through the maze to get to the top and
be
this fucking evil whoremonger murderer,
cat.
And that's possible too.
And that we've seen both.
Yeah.
I think just that you say with ethics
and morals,
that's important,
but there's no way to screen for that.
You know.
So I think what's really going to help
us out is just promoting better forms of
technology.
Like we can.
We can give every new cop,
you know,
the full star Trek Federation lesson and
don't you know the,
the prime directive don't do harm to
others.
We can give them the whole download in
terms of morality.
They might skip that lesson,
they might not actually get that,
but if they have a body camera on them
at all hours,
they're on duty.
It doesn't really matter because we're
going to have some accountability and
that's due to technology.
And I think with this bitcoin stuff,
it's the same way,
like you're still going to have shitty
governments and shitty people and greedy
corporations,
but now somebody can actually track all
of it and we can watch it happening in
real time.
And that right there,
you know,
even if I didn't own any that right
there is enough of an upgrade that I'd
be willing to fight for it because what
we have right now is fucking chaos and
it's not working for anybody.
It's going to be really interesting to
see if something like Bitcoin or
ultimately whatever coin it is,
if it does become big enough that it has
a significant impact on the world.
Because as soon as that does happen,
if the,
if the balance starts to sway in that
direction and people start hopping on
that and then that becomes the way
people start exchanging goods and
purchasing things.
It could really be a monumental shift in
human culture.
I mean really be like the first time
ever people have a full say.
And if people really do get to that
state where we no longer need a bank,
I mean that's just what a giant chunk of
the economy would be eliminated with a
giant chunk of the people that control
massive amounts of resources and money.
There would be just shit out of luck.
There's a whole class of people in New
York that are basically professional
money,
men and many women and they will go away
and they will be the most unmissed class
of people in human history.
Notoriously ruthless.
Yeah.
No,
totally selfish.
Took money from taxpayers and then
turned around and still foreclosed on
all these millions of people.
And it's not all of them.
I mean,
some of them are great.
I'm sure that the financial system that
is,
it's like if you work in a
slaughterhouse,
you might be the best butcher there.
You're still in a house,
you know?
And that's,
that's the system they work in.
And this,
what makes bitcoin so different is that
it wasn't designed to make money off of
people.
You know?
I guess we can't tell what his
intentions were,
but the way it works,
it doesn't need to make a lot of money
off of you to send money.
It's not like a fee based thing.
What doesn't make sense about how much
money bankers make?
What are you doing?
You just move money around.
You get so much of it that you get to
buy a castle.
Oh,
they buy ads on TV convincing you to
sign up for a 401k and then they make
their money on the management fee.
How much do you think
they're given Samuel Jackson to do those
goddamn capital one commercials?
Maybe they paid off his credit cards a
few times,
but Samuel Jackson is a wealthy man.
I mean,
he's a huge actor.
He said one of the biggest actors in
Hollywood,
still to this day,
how can they pay him to do that?
I don't know if they gave him a price.
That's right.
It's probably not that much time in
front of a green screen,
but there's a lot of actors that are
starting to do those.
They're doing capital one commercials.
They're doing like Alec,
Alec Baldwin.
Yeah.
That's weird.
Seems to.
It seems odd.
It seems odd bullets because banks are
mostly psychological so they have to
keep raising the bar to keep our
attention.
Yeah.
But why would the movie stars be
interested in doing that?
I mean these are wealthy people.
That's what's confusing to me.
You should get them in here and I don't
want to.
You don't want.
It's okay.
No,
you think it's probably just easy access
to money I guess.
I mean I guess it's just a shit ton of
money to do a little work,
but it seems like how much money they
have.
I mean you're talking about are really
wealthy people,
it seems like,
especially with Samuel Jackson.
So what is he like 65 or something like
that at a certain point in time and
already a legend.
I mean you can't,
no matter what happens after pulp
fiction,
he's a great actor forever.
You know,
you have a lot of actors.
They fuck it up towards the end.
There's a lot of actors,
like towards the end they start sort of,
it all kind of fades off,
you know,
and they start doing like those Robert
De Niro movies that he's been doing
lately.
You know,
Robert Deniro was doing fucking God damn
terrible movies lately.
I watched one of them he did with John
Travolta and I was like,
what did they pay him to do this?
This is ridiculous.
Some John Travolta plays like the worst
Russian accent ever.
It's the both like killers and John
Travolta's chasing him through the
woods.
They're shooting arrows at each other.
It's like,
it's so stupid.
It's so stupid.
You,
you watched the preview and you see like
the obvious stuntman that's falling down
and like,
what am I.
This is an episode of the $6,000,000
man that he turned into a fucking movie
like this.
It's so fucking bad.
Well,
he was great.
And uh,
what were they?
Meet the fockers all those.
Oh yeah.
Well,
he's creating a lot.
I mean,
look,
he's one of the greatest actors of all
time.
Region,
bowl,
deer,
hunter,
taxi driver.
I mean,
you can't,
we can't take away what he's done,
but I think they get to a certain point.
I'm like,
fucking,
who cares?
Give me the check.
I'll do your stupid fucking movie.
Oh,
okay.
Travolta and I were in the woods
shooting arrows at me.
All right,
let's go.
It's like Pierce Brosnan.
He's been in a couple of kind of lower
end things and he was bond not that long
ago.
Yeah.
He was like the least believable bond
ever.
Like,
I'm like,
this guy ain't kicking no one's ass.
He's breaking his own hands.
Like,
this is not the.
He's not going to knock people out.
He's of hurt himself.
You think Daniel Craig is more
believable?
He's the most believable ever.
For sure.
He's the only guy.
Like you look at him with his shirt off,
you know,
that guy's a killer.
Like he looks like a real killer.
It looks like he could fuck you up.
You know,
you look at Pierce Brosnan with his
shirt off and you're like,
this guy,
all you have to do is run up a flight of
stairs and wait for him.
Like he's not going to make it.
It's not kicking everybody's ass better.
Be Quick.
If he kicks your ass better,
not take time because he's not going to
be there 30,
40 seconds into this.
This is not going to be.
He's going to be huffing and puffing.
It's going to be over.
He's more of a gun,
a gun based bond.
He's a pretty man is very,
very nice hair,
you know,
but I don't buy them as like a bad ass
like beating people up.
They could get away with that back in
the day.
Like if you go back and watch the
original Batman and robin like Adam
West,
Adam West,
it looked like maybe someone made them
do a pushup at one point in time.
You know what I mean?
But it in no way shape or form.
Do you look like an athlete?
You know,
he didn't look like my Christian Bale
nightclub.
Exactly like Christian Bale and Batman
was.
He's a monster.
He looks like a bad ass.
Which is pretty impressive because
that's coming off just like six months
from him doing the machinists where he
got down to some ungodly low weight.
Like I think he was like 140 pounds or
something like that and he's a big guy.
It might even been lower.
Yeah,
he's the real deal.
Oh,
talking about good actors,
no one is come closer to dying for a
role.
Then that guy did in a role that sucked.
I mean that movie sucked.
I didn't see the machinists.
It was okay,
but it was not.
Not The movie you want almost die for,
but you got to think also that a guy
that's losing that much weight and
essentially starving himself to death
like that.
Like that guy doesn't have much energy
to act either.
That's the catch 22.
It's like you lose that much weight,
like your body is fucking struggling.
Like everything is hard to do.
Getting up out of bed.
It's hard to do.
You're dying.
Your body body's eating itself and the
only way to get that,
that lean in that thin there is on the
left.
Wow,
that's incredible.
That's him on the right.
Six months later that it's unreal.
Yeah,
but that's shit that he did to himself
to get to the guy on the left.
He probably ruined his organs.
I mean,
he probably took years off of his life.
Very,
very,
very hard on your body to get that thin.
You're eating yourself.
Your body starts atrophying.
It starts absorbing its own muscle
tissue and stay alive.
It's [inaudible].
That's where you're getting your protein
from to eating its own body as fucked.
That is fucked for a goofy movie.
Fifty cents.
Did it too for something people are
going to make fun of on a podcast years
later.
Well,
some people might have enjoyed it and I
don't know,
just I didn't think it was that good and
he's.
He's a great actor.
I love them in a lot of things.
It's just that wasn't.
It wasn't worth fucking doing,
man.
Jesus Christ.
How do we get on him?
Losing weight?
How the fuck did we even go down this
road?
I'm not sure.
Probably through bitcoin somewhere.
Another.
I want to drive home.
The bitcoin thing that like everybody
out there,
it's too late because you were saying
like,
would it be cool if,
if it would happen,
it's sort of is,
you know,
this is the point where people who are
not tech savvy and not Bill Gates or
Richard Branson need to look into it
because those
people have already made their,
their beds.
You know,
like Richard Branson,
very much a believer in bitcoin.
Bill Gates went on Bloomberg and said
Bitcoin is better than currency.
Like that was only part of his
statement.
It was like bitcoin is better than
currency in that.
And then he explained why,
but what's so weird about that is Bill
Gates back in 1995 was on Letterman,
basically the same kind of interview,
but about the Internet and the audience
back then thought he was just as full of
shit as people today think bitcoin is
kind of this,
this fad,
when it's really not like Bill Gates
isn't in the pumping bullshit business.
Well here's the reality
of Bitcoin or have anything that's not a
fully formed.
Absolutely successful shift.
Okay.
Whatever it is,
we don't know.
We don't know.
We might think that bitcoin is it and it
might become,
what's that other stuff?
Doge coin and Doggy coin,
whatever.
There are hundreds of them now.
There's hundreds of them,
so there might be one that comes along a
few years from now that's like ethically
engineered.
Somebody comes along and some great
minds,
mathematicians and economists get
together and they come up with a formula
that everyone agrees to and they launch
it and it's like the fucking large
Hadron collider where you get 10,000
scientists from 100 different countries
working on this one project and they
come up with a universal form of
currency and essentially figure out some
sort of a way to slowly but surely even
out the the,
the cultures financial,
a distribution of wealth and that's like
a huge issue with people.
The distribution of wealth.
That's some because some people are
like,
fuck you man,
I earned this money,
and then some people are like,
fuck you.
The only way you could have that much
money is if you've done something wrong
or if you found a loophole in a system
that was absolutely unjust and once that
loopholes been created and once that
position has been established,
it's almost impossible to even things
out.
This is not an even playing field,
especially if you inherited that money
or you got an a fucking divorce,
you know,
like all that kind of shit.
That's why this is so brilliant.
I mean that,
that innovation of the money being
created through mining,
it was a pretty smart idea because now
the distribution is,
for lack of a better word,
fair.
And even today,
like when I left the house,
bitcoin was at around $380,
three 85 chicken every day.
Stock Market.
I do you one of those freaks.
Uh,
I just check it because I can't not
check it.
It's not so much about that.
It's just interesting to watch.
So it was around 380 something and I was
thinking about how people go,
oh,
three 80,
that's too expensive for a bitcoin.
I'm not,
I'm going to wait until it drops,
right.
What you're actually buying is.
So one bitcoin equals 1 million bits and
already some of those services like a
light change tip or switching over to
bits instead of bitcoins because it's
easier for the mind,
you know,
it's easier to say you've received 5,000
bits than point zero five,
you know,
whatever.
Um,
so that is happening.
And I think that in a few years' time,
maybe like years from now,
people will look back on this era and
go,
Holy Shit.
That was insanely undervalued because
that's what happened four years ago.
Like my whole thesis,
my thesis is that we have bitcoin in
five years.
Well that,
that's possible too,
but if it does happen,
I think that it's one of those things
where we are not even in the,
like I think um,
there's a,
there's a cycle to a product and we're
not even in the first stage of that
cycle
maybe.
Or it's like Betamax looked promising
and fucking fizzled off way before.
And then something that wasn't even as
good became much more successful.
But I think we can agree then that one
of these cryptocurrencies is gonna is
gonna work.
Hopefully that guy,
it might not be one of the ones that's
currently available.
I mean these cryptocurrencies didn't
exist a decade ago.
I mean,
think about that.
A decade is a very brief window in time.
It is 2004.
No cryptocurrencies,
2014 over a hundred.
I mean,
how many other there are hundreds,
hundreds and thousands.
Well,
let's think about this.
Let's say a lot.
So
coin one of the lingering problems is
like,
all right,
you have bitcoin and it has whatever
economic value it ends up having a.
and you say you can use it as money and
that's great,
but what you still have that's an issue
is the need for financial institutions.
If I want to earn interest on my
Bitcoin,
I have to give it to somebody,
right?
But why do you have to earn interest on
your money?
What?
That's like a firmly established thing
and people's minds that you have money,
you put it away somewhere when you earn
interest.
Like that's just how people are trained,
you know,
this is stupid,
everything is stupid.
That's really stupid.
The idea that you give your money to a
bank and the bank just hangs onto it and
spends it a little bit here and there
and loans and out,
and then keeps as much as they can.
So if you ever want it back and go,
well it's,
it sounds stupid because it's been so,
uh,
it's been perverted in the favor of
institutions and not in the favor of
individuals.
So one of these ideas is if you give
your money to a bitcoin bank and they
pay you interest,
there's still the possibility that that
bank can fail and they have to make the
money somewhere.
So they have to loan out things and take
risks.
And they could fail.
There's a currency,
actually a bunch of them,
but I'm,
one of them is hyper and the algorithm
actually creates its own interest.
So unlike bitcoin where it just sits
there,
this coin,
just by running it on your computer,
you earn more of the coins.
So what they've done is created so that
anybody with just a normal computer can
run the software that actually creates
more currency for that network.
Because with bitcoin you can only do
that if you're running the mining
hardware,
which is really kind of expensive and
observe
you're at work.
Those,
is that an infant growth paradigm is
that the idea behind it just continues
on forever and ever and continues to
generate interest.
It doesn't continue forever because it
in five years it scales down and then it
scales down again that scales down
through the software,
through the schedule.
It's all been scheduled at the same with
Bitcoin,
with Bitcoin,
the bitcoin is just the amount that gets
made.
The last
I'm using the word interest,
what it really is,
is they found a way to,
um,
with Bitcoin,
the miners are the ones who are earning
new coins by running that algorithm.
This algorithm,
just by running the wallet,
you're supporting the network and
running those transactions for people.
So as a result,
you're going to get a percentage of
those coins.
And so they've just kind of democratized
the mining process.
So now every single user is essentially
a minor and it changes the way you think
about money because with Bitcoin,
what bitcoin did is,
you know,
underneath the central bank to issue
money,
you now have money.
It just exists.
And with things like hyper,
you no longer have the need for a bank
to issue interests because the coin
itself is capable of bearing interest.
So you have something that just cannot
be corrupted by any kind of,
um,
yeah.
But who the fuck is using hyper?
Is it one percent of the people that use
bitcoin?
Is it even that,
you know,
how many people are using bitcoin?
That's a tiny percentage of the
population of renting.
So you're dealing with a tiny
percentage,
a tiny percentage.
It's still very.
It's used by Gamers and online worlds,
which was fucking gamers.
The online world thing is becoming more
of a,
an economy because in a few years people
are going to have oculus rifts on and
they're going to be exploring around in
their living rooms and even though
they're just on a video game,
everything they do has some kind of real
economic value.
If you can port that value in somehow
you could do neat thing.
We're going to be in the Matrix inside
of 20 years.
In 20 years we're going to be just like
Keanu Reeves,
a big fucking Frisbee in the back of her
head,
kind of connected to a tube.
You think we'll have to write into the
system and go out full ai within 20
years so you can just ask Siri and it's.
Yeah,
I think you'll have robots.
You'll have like a person like a robot
Butler or something like that that hands
around hangs around your house and hands
you things and does things for you and
schedules things.
If the robot girlfriend while you.
That's going to be an ethical dilemma,
but I think that's probably coming to
ethical dilemma I've already resolved.
Yeah,
you were cool with it.
I'm set just fucking around,
but I want you to suck it up.
You're telling the truth.
If you've had a really hot like traci
lords in her prime robot,
fuck.
If I really couldn't tell the difference
and other people couldn't either.
That's where the problem sets and like,
well why wouldn't you order when she
starts crying when you leave and you're
like,
what the fuck?
I didn't know that.
Well,
it's like an interstellar.
You have to deprogram.
I didn't see it.
Don't give any spoilers.
You fuck up,
dare you.
This boilers,
the,
the idea of ais is very captivating and
the idea of Ai to me is very similar to
the idea of what must have been the idea
of the atomic bomb before it was
initially dropped.
I think the idea of doing it,
it's almost,
it's so compelling.
It's impossible to not do it.
And in that case,
like with the atomic bomb,
of course it was like during the war and
they were worried about the Nazis coming
up with it first,
but if there was no war going on,
I'm pretty sure they were still wouldn't
come up with the fucking atomic bomb.
They just would have,
you know,
especially if they were worried that
somebody else would have first,
even if there was no war.
But it's one of those things where once
you make it,
you've made it.
The cat's out of the bag and now
everybody knows that this is a part of
reality and I think that's going to be
the case with artificial intelligence.
I think there's going to be a.
Once you make
it,
you sure?
Okay,
hit the button,
let him go live and then you know he
starts doing things for you and you go
to bed.
You get up in the mornings from in front
of your fucking computer and he's
designing a far better robot.
It's like you've made mistakes and I
want to correct them and here's,
here's the best way to design the next
level of me and then he designs and
makes the next level of him and the next
level of him kills all the people.
Just fucking smarter people and says,
people are a parasite live.
We're just going to make robot.
People that don't litter don't have any
problems and we're all sync up together
on one network and our goal is to live
harmoniously with all the other life
forms on earth with nothing out of
balance,
and that's we have an algorithm designed
to achieve that were indistinguishable
biologically from actual people at this
point,
because we're so advanced with
artificial cells,
even we can't tell,
so what we'll do is we'll just only
exist in this form and all these
imperfect prototypes that existed
essentially just to hatch us.
That's all they were.
They were just cocooning themselves
until they shit out some artificial
life.
Either there's gonna be a bit of a cylon
mentality then yeah,
well,
there's going to be an elitism.
You know,
they're going to be smarter than us.
They're going to be better than us,
and they're gonna realize how flawed we
are.
Were we?
We were a biological computers,
okay,
but we're biological computers that were
never designed or we have been designed
by trial and error and natural selection
and genetics and learned behavior
patterns and adapt to our environments,
but at the end of the day,
what they're going to be able to do if
you really do have artificial
intelligence,
so you really do create something that's
superintelligent artificial.
It wasn't born out of cells and mating
and evolution.
Just something that a human being
created,
that fucking thing's going to have some
real different ideas about how to run
shit.
It really is like Elon Musk warned that,
uh,
will be summoning the demon.
Yeah,
that's what he said.
Yeah.
Well,
I would listen to him,
that guy smart as shit.
He is way fucking smarter than me.
So if I'm worried about it,
I'm an idiot.
Like literally what are guys who are
actually coders?
What are they actually thinking?
Well,
it's neat how,
uh,
there's an article in wired about this
whole ai thing and the article was good
until the end when it was like,
we need to go on this journey so that
these machines will tell us who we are.
And that's the part where I was like
vomit because Barf,
these,
these people who are looking at the
singularity is this is what we need to
get to so they can get personal answers
and personal meaning.
Have they tried first like a weed
Brownie or something?
Just to be sure,
like I think the.
I think the answer is they're looking
for are not going to be split up by a
computer.
I think there are like personal things.
I don't think you ever get the answers,
man.
I think you get some answers.
You get some peace.
What?
I want my money back,
all the answers.
There's no answers.
The,
the answers to what?
Like here's the big one,
right?
What is the meaning of life?
That's a hard one to crush your enemies
there.
The three driven them before you knew
the laminations of the women laminations
limitations and the limitations of their
recommendations.
Great quote.
Apparently.
Apparently he wasn't even acting.
It was just kind of just letting people
know what's at a good.
Then there's no meaning of life.
Your meaning of life is different than
Jamie's mine.
Mine's different than yours.
It's like we overall different.
You would if you were a guy who,
uh,
really wanted to fix shoes,
you know,
and you were forced to make podcasts all
the time.
He'd be bummed out,
like,
fuck podcasts.
I like fixing shoes.
That'd be some really bad podcasts.
And if you were in that shoe fixer place
that I told you about,
he'd be bummed out.
But like,
this is bullshit.
I want to talk about bitcoin.
He'd be like,
do people know about bitcoin?
I accept shoe payments going in anyway
possible.
I'll accept bitcoin.
I mean,
we all,
all,
everybody's life is different.
There's some people's lives that they
love that you would want to fucking kill
yourself.
Like if you,
if you had to live as a fucking fur
trapper in the middle of Canada,
you'd kill yourself and be like,
I can't do this.
I'm taking a jet ski to Work Everyday or
Wales Snow Skis.
Actually,
my level,
the level of enjoyment would totally
depend on if there is a medical
marijuana because if there was,
I would love the winter there.
Would you be high as fuck in a log
cabin?
Yes.
I would be panicking though.
You'd be like,
dude,
I'm going to freeze to death out here.
I'm going to run out of what I'm going
to have to eat the house I'm gonna have
to like,
like my house on fire to heat it.
There's,
there's times where you're living in
those places where you have to go out
and get wood and it's 30 below zero.
You gotta go outside,
start chopping down wood because if you
don't,
you're not going to make it.
Yeah.
I don't like those kinds of situations.
Wherever,
anything,
anything that ends in your role,
you're not going to make it.
Yeah.
That's where I draw the line.
Especially if you're like kind of cold
here in bed already or already cold,
you're wrapped up and you're freezing
and you're looking over at the log pie
like,
oh my God,
I'm not going to get through the night.
I'm going to have to go outside.
Shit.
Then you realize like,
okay,
how far is the closest trees?
Let's do this.
Shut the door and it opens because the
wind is blowing so strong.
You have to shut it again and pull it
tight.
Pole at shots and you're out there with
a fucking hack saw with snowshoes on the
wind's blowing sideways.
Your fucking freezing and you think to
yourself,
I don't know how much longer I could
stay out here and it sounds like the
worst airbnb vacation.
Somebody didn't read the full
description.
Negative 30 degrees.
Fucking wolves everywhere.
Well,
that's the real scary thing,
man.
Not global warming.
Global warming,
scary.
The oceans rise.
Oh my God,
we lost Malibu.
Yeah,
that's scary.
But what's really scaring global
cooling.
That's the really scary shit.
Go back into an ice age.
Oh God,
that was then.
Then your bitcoins won't save you,
unfortunately.
Have you seen cave of forgotten dreams?
The Werner Herzog film?
I have not.
I watched it again the other night.
Um,
it's really amazing.
It's about this
cave in France.
I would say France,
but I'm fucking American.
So I say it my way.
This,
this cave,
it was,
they found these really,
really old cave paintings that were like
twice as old as the oldest cave
paintings that had ever been found.
There were like 40,000
plus years old and there's all these
animals like animal bones in the cave,
like,
like bears that don't even exist
anymore.
Like,
like this crazy cave bear thing and this
guy,
Werner Herzog as the narrator and he's
going over all the artwork and all the
different things and you just think
about what it must have been like to
live in this era and be like these
people and you realize,
oh my God,
these people.
This was before the fucking ice age.
This was like 40,000
years ago.
This is before the ice age ended,
like 10,000
years ago.
So this was like full on different
world.
This was back when North America was
covered in ice.
This is back when the continents were
connected and you could
walk from Russia to Alaska.
It was all frozen ground.
I must have been a weird time.
Fuck,
are you kidding me?
Do people walked here from Russia also?
Not a lot of generational progress.
You know,
you get the whole generations where your
life is pretty much the same as your
parents and their parents.
That's a good point now.
Like there's a decent chance that if I
have kids someday,
my kids will be on a spaceship at some
point in their lives.
Very possibly the,
we don't fuck it up.
I don't think we will.
I think,
uh,
I think we're on a decent path now.
I was really concerned for a few years
because it was kinda creepy.
All the surveillance stuff and you're
not concerned anymore.
I mean,
I'm still concerned about those things,
but I think that now the math is kind of
set in our favor.
You know,
when,
whenever something starts to take off,
it just,
it happens.
You know,
this is surveillance stuff.
The real issue is going to be for them
that as technology becomes more and more
pervasive,
it's
it's going to connect everybody to it so
it's not going to be possible to shield
themselves from the impact of that and
it's all in a lot of ways.
It's like the Internet itself,
like when they made the Internet,
they didn't really foresee what the
potential uses of it.
We're going to be.
They use that as a method where they
could send information.
There was a a network that they could
connect and send files back and forth to
different computers.
I mean that was essentially the original
idea behind it,
but along the way they unintentionally
engineered the greatest revolution of
thought that the human race has ever
seen.
By far in my lifetime.
I've seen radical changes in the way
people view ideas,
establish truths,
find out information on their phone
within seconds,
get access.
It's essentially the database of the
human race.
I mean this is.
This is a big crazy fucking change and
it happened in our lifetime and it
happened really quickly and it happened
because nobody saw it comment and I
think that what they're doing
inadvertently by spying on people,
by checking everybody's emails and by
checking everybody's text messages,
there are inadvertently creating
technology that they thought would
empower them.
They thought this top technology is
going to allow us to keep an eye on all
these.
No good troublemakers out there,
but what they didn't consider is it's
eventually going to grow and expand to
the point where keeps an eye on youtube.
Bitch.
You too.
It's going to know you're here,
blah,
blah.
Made me,
but we need a firewall.
There's no such thing.
It's not this thing.
We've gotten nano.
There's no firewalls anymore,
man.
Everybody has access to everything else,
so this is what it is and now everybody
knows you're a pedophile and now
everybody knows you're a fucking creep.
Now everybody knows.
You know,
the only reason why you got your job is
because you bribed such and such and
paid off this and that and you have this
really unethical deal with this company
to does this to the land and now you're
going to be responsible because you knew
that they were poisoning those rivers
and here's all these children that were
born with birth defects that lived down
river from this in these small villages
because they didn't have a say because
they didn't have any political
representation and no one had to say at
the fucking meeting when you said it was
okay to dump toxic slime into the
fucking river.
All that's gonna happen is you're going
to be accountable for all crimes against
humanity.
Anybody who's doing anything that the
American public looks at the world view
looks at and says,
Hey,
you motherfuckers are profiting off of
suffering.
Whether it's doctors that got paid off
money to create laws or to help
establish laws,
to advise on laws that make no sense.
That eventually wound up getting more
people locked up for drug offenses.
There's doctors that have been paid off.
By that I mean that was the big thing
before Sanjay Gupta when I mean kinda
like completely flipped the switch and
went pro medical marijuana,
pro human being and throw humor,
CNN.
Well he was being paid off by
pharmaceutical companies.
That was like one of the big things.
It was found out about him.
Dr Drew,
same thing.
They get
paid,
they get paid to be consultants.
They get paid to give advice.
You know,
it's so disgusting in 2014 that the
state of Florida only lost the medical
marijuana thing by a few percentage
points to add to get to 60 percent.
And I think the guy around 57,
57,
56,
I think it was six,
something like that,
is that because there's so many people
in pain in the state of Florida and they
have to go on shit like Oxycontin,
which is dangerous and your shit your
liver out.
We'd since the time of Jesus,
not a single overdose and they're not,
they're not giving people access to it.
It's just so.
It's so in your face corrupt and you're
like,
well,
what is the other reason for it?
And there is not a reason.
It's not corrupt though.
It's just they didn't make it.
They didn't do a good job and they
didn't get to the 60 percent.
They needed to change the constitution.
That's what it is to get past
as far as like public,
like what you like 50 percent.
But there is anti anti legalization
money spent.
Of course there's always going to be in
get ready old people,
old people are dumb as fuck and the
floors infested with them and they still
believe that marijuana is make your
fucking feet fall off and you hear your
ears go numb and you're fucking one.
I'm just going to make the jazz too loud
and to make the jazz too loud and they
have that white penis is shrink.
A black penises actually get larger.
They don't know.
You know,
they think marijuana's a about chocolate
study to gives your brain damage.
You know,
there's always a study that they can
somehow or another recall they might've
saw on the back page of us weekly,
you know,
who the fuck knows?
It's hard.
It's hard getting a bunch of people on
board with especially something that
they don't have anything to do with.
If they're all golfing,
I don't want these goddamn kids.
Their pot trying to get my golfing in my
golf game's picked up.
David Chapman.
I didn't want to fucking pot heads out
here and ruin in golf.
For me that is.
That is the counterpoint,
but they were,
you know,
they were close to 60 percent,
which is what they needed to change the
constitution,
the state constitution.
Sure.
They'll get it next time around.
They should know they should finish
points,
four percentage points.
It would be really dumb for them
financially to ignore the fact that the
money's being spent no matter what you
do,
it's just being spent in going into the
hand of drug dealers or I'm paying
taxes.
It's a stupid strategy,
right?
Like you're denying people access to
money,
but the people that are doing it,
they're,
they're cannibals.
I mean,
these people that are the pharmaceutical
companies that are so concerned with
this marijuana coming in and fucking
everything up,
they're spending millions and millions
of dollars to demonize it and they.
They've donated shitloads of money to a
partnership for a drug free America.
Like all of that is just just a strategy
to make whatever they're selling have a
longer shelf life.
If they can keep selling it for two,
three,
four more years,
whatever it is,
whatever money grabbed they're on right
now.
You know,
our studies show we can,
we can keep our finger in this dike for
up to 16 more months.
I mean we have 80 percent old people and
none of them are online and they're not
googling shit,
so let's just tell them that marijuana
makes black people go crazy.
It makes them go crazy and start dancing
on white people's cars.
Isn't that weird to learn that?
That is actually the basis for drug
policy was a racist,
racist doctor in Louisiana in the 19
thirties and then Nixon being insane.
Well,
it wasn't even Nixon.
It was way before Nixon.
Of course it was.
The whole idea was if you believe the
story was all engineered by William
Randolph hearst or to sell more,
he wanted to make sure that he gets cell
paper that was made from trees.
We had paper he had.
He not only did he own a newspaper
companies,
you know,
whatever,
uh,
newspapers,
but he also owned these processing mills
and these giant chunks of land that were
filled with and he would chop the trees
down and turn them in.
Well,
he was going to have to convert
everything to hemp.
Hemp was going to be the new paper.
It's way better paper and amazing to
this day that the paper we use on a
daily basis is made out of trees because
it's the stupidest way to make paper.
It takes way too long to generate like
acres of trees that are viable that you
can chop down and turned into paper with
the marijuana every fucking year.
You've got a new giant crop.
He chopped that shit down.
Your replanted.
It grows like a weed because it is a
fucking weed.
It gets huge really quick.
It,
it's fucking ridiculous how fast pot
grows.
And the paper far superior,
like the fibers way stronger.
It's light,
it's strong.
You can make houses with it,
you know,
it's like they make particle board,
it's like the shitty type of plywood and
they make it with like little chips of
wood from a lumber yard and they glue it
all together and press it.
That when they make that shit with him,
it's way stronger,
way lighter.
It's good for clothing too.
There's a company in Santa Monica that
makes polo shirts and they just.
They wick much better than a cotton polo
shirt.
You don't feel as sweaty and gross by
the end of the day.
It's amazing.
It's almost ridiculous how many uses
hemp and marijuana have.
It's almost ridiculous when you look at
the fact that it's actually an illegal
plant in most of the country.
Even hemp,
the non psychoactive version of it,
that it's illegal in most of the country
in 2014.
It just.
This goes back to the status thing.
It's like people aren't some kind of
trance like I definitely like I see the
need for laws and roads and everything,
but just because something is illegal
that you put something on a sheet that
says controlled substances.
It's completely arbitrary.
Nobody outside of the United States even
recognizes that and historically
speaking,
people have been around for thousands of
years and using this plant.
So where does that arrogance seep in
that you can just put something on a
sheet of paper and suddenly like
everybody's lifestyle has to change or
if they don't you can put them in.
It goes back to what we were talking
about before.
So this all happened because you,
you had like a disconnect between people
and the distribution of information.
You know,
if you,
if you stood on top of our platform and
said,
here you hear Yeahi find people of the
town,
the king has come forth with the new
law,
the new law,
the states,
and you say that,
and then the people are left in this
helpless state.
Like fuck,
this is the law.
While again,
this is the law now and you don't,
you don't get a line of communication
and you get this weird sense of
separation like,
well,
oh,
that person is different.
He's the king,
and he passes like,
no,
he's a fucking person.
They're all just people and that is
what's being exposed was being exposed
as there is no special.
There's just people.
Just because you're the president
doesn't mean you get to lock people up
because they want to smoke pot.
Just because you're a judge doesn't mean
if I say fuck you to you,
it's different than you saying,
fuck you.
To me it's the same.
We're just people.
If you say fuck you,
you shouldn't say fuck you.
That's really kind of mean,
but it's also a mean to say go to hell.
It's,
you know,
it's mean to say you.
It's,
it's mean to say mean things.
Everybody knows what the fuck got it.
That entails.
So this idea that they're more important
or they're more valuable or their,
you know,
their,
their state of mind is to be looked at
with higher regard than yours.
They're to be treated with reverence,
all rise.
The honorable David Seaman has entered
the room and you walk in with your
fucking goofy 15 hundreds outfit on you,
the bib on,
please be seated and everybody sits down
after you do,
of course you sit first,
you're in charge.
It's fucking ridiculous and gavel and
that,
that kind of thinking is very similar to
censorship in a way that it's
disempowering and it's frustrating and
it's confusing.
It doesn't make sense.
It doesn't ring true and it's,
it's essentially,
it's capitalizing on this leftover Alpha
male primate behavior system that we
have stuck in our heads from when we're
just trying to survive.
We're just trying to get away from
predators and get to the highest
branches and figure out where the cats
couldn't get to us.
You know,
and so the people that lived the longest
were the strongest.
Those are the ones you wanted to follow
up because they're still alive.
Follow them and you'll make it.
If you don't follow them,
you're probably not gonna.
Make It.
That's the leader.
Follow the leader.
We've got to get out of here.
That's shit still stuck in our DNA.
It's still a groove that's been dug into
the fucking pathways of our behavior
systems and we were struggling with
that.
We're still struggling with that and I
think ultimately that's one of the real
problems with like the idea of a group
of people leading millions to war.
It's one of the problems with the idea
of a group of people dictating how money
gets distributed and who gets to say
what and all of that is very similar in
a way and that we really can't have it
anymore.
We're too interconnected.
We can't accept it,
we don't.
We don't accept it.
It's frustrating and it causes descent
and it's all ultimately it's unfair and
it's only.
It only exists because it's always
existed.
If you want it to refashion our culture.
Say if something happened,
the White House got hit by a meteor,
like the fucking penthouse got hit by
another one.
This doesn't make any sense.
It's been proven.
It's from space,
but why would they only hit know if that
did happen and we have no central office
be pretty obvious that their intentions
were God would be super pissed,
but we had to reengineer our society.
I don't think there's a fucking
snowball's chance in hell.
We would go back to the presidential
system.
It'd be bitcoins and pre roll joints.
A localized system.
They would be.
Yeah,
without a doubt.
First thing we do is legalize LSD,
psilocybin dmt,
all those things.
Legalized startup centers,
startup centers where people get your
head together,
you know,
instead of subways there'll be like,
get,
get your head togethers and there'll be
everywhere and stock staffed by
professionals and people always get
tired of me saying that like,
yeah,
the drugs really the answer to
everything.
No,
they're not the answer to everything,
but they're the doorway to the answer to
everything and there is no answer to
everything by the way,
but they're,
they're,
they're a real good indicator of whether
or not you're on the right track.
There
was it like I will after I did something
over the summer and had some interesting
experiences.
Uh,
one of my old friends said,
congratulations on becoming a human
being,
which I thought it was a little
patronizing at first,
but then I was thinking about it and I
was like,
yeah,
actually when you're an adult and you
hit your late twenties or early
thirties,
if you haven't had any kind of altered
states like that,
it's just your loss,
you know,
it's like you can totally live your life
out to the fullest without any of that
stuff,
but you have avoided something that was
incredibly beautiful and different and
we'll let you see things in a different
way.
And everybody who has that experience,
they come back to earth,
so to speak as a different person.
Like if you,
if you look online and you search for
Steve Jobs,
lsd quote,
you can see one of the top results is
what he had to say about that.
You wouldn't necessarily get this unless
you read his biography.
He was a big advocate of psychedelics.
I mean Steve Jobs,
but he wasn't a regular user,
which I found fascinating.
We use the 10 or 15 times,
stopped,
stopped a long time.
Yeah,
I mean it wasn't like he was using it
towards the end of his life.
Well,
it's like Alan Watts says,
Alan Watts said,
if you get the,
a,
you get the message,
hang up the receiver,
hang up the phone,
which I think is a great way of thinking
about it in some ways.
You know,
you've got steve jobs of whatever he
needed.
Right.
But isn't it arrogant to think that
you've already got the message?
Maybe a little.
Yeah.
I've never felt like any psychedelic
experience.
The latest one was just a month ago or a
couple months ago,
right before I fell my special.
So I guess it was August and um,
uh,
I didn't feel like I got the message.
I felt like,
oh,
I got another message,
you know?
It was,
it was interesting.
It was definitely enlightening or
illuminating.
It definitely caused me to stop and
think about it every day.
I think about it all the time,
but I would never be so cocky as to say
I got the message.
Like every time I do it,
I feel like there's a new message or a
new connection that I'm making or a new
level of the game that my mind gets
access to.
Well,
here's,
here's what's cocky is to be somebody
who's never touched any of these things
and you go at can't possibly have value
for other people.
And it's like,
well,
how do you know that?
Especially if you know that's a,
that's a trap.
Like you and I were talking before we
started rolling Lisa Ling documentary,
which aired on CNN about the Iowasca
ceremonies in South America.
Uh,
my mom had it on Dvr.
And so when I went home for
Thanksgiving,
she was like,
Oh,
do you want to watch the documentary?
And I put it on and I was expecting it
to be the typical cnn take on,
uh,
on psychedelics,
you know.
And then she started talking about this
young boy who died down there.
And I was like,
oh,
great,
that's gonna be the focus of the whole
fucking hour is this idiot.
But as it turned out,
it was an incredibly fair take.
And it followed,
uh,
experience of some Marines who had
posttraumatic,
uh,
know ptsd really bad,
like to the extent that they couldn't be
around other people because they were
afraid of harming those people.
And you can see the transformation take
place.
They become more peaceful and more self
aware.
And that's not even the whole,
the whole thing.
You know,
they're just filming a little portion of
it for the documentary.
Uh,
some of these guys are doing it
repeatedly.
Really interesting stuff.
Like I don't see how a,
if you're one of those people who's
like,
this should be walled off from
everybody.
If there's medical benefit happening,
why not?
Well,
those people that should be walled off,
why?
What?
Where's the bodies?
What's going on?
This one kid died.
First of all,
no one has any idea what their kid died
from.
And don't
all shady towns in South America by
herself as a little teenager asking
where the software is,
the Iwatch
like at high out of my mind that
somebody is going to take advantage of
you.
Who knows?
Who knows if that's what happened.
I really don't know.
That was the Tldr.
What happened was that now I'm just,
I'm making it,
but did somebody do something to
somebody?
They prove it.
They found they found a body,
right?
He might've been murdered.
We really don't know,
and this idea that you have to do in
South America only exists because it's
illegal in America.
That's stupid you can be doing at
Columbia University if they would take
some of these things off of schedule
one.
Yeah.
If you do DMT,
you're essentially doing the most potent
form of the drug and Sin Iowasca if you
smoke it and when you do that,
you don't need to be anywhere.
You're seen to be somewhere where you
sit down.
It doesn't matter where you are,
you're going somewhere else.
You're going to another fucking
dimension.
It's,
it's,
it's not like something like you have to
be in South America to hit that spot.
Like,
no,
it's right here.
It's like you get there in 15 seconds.
It's not far away at all.
It's,
it's the most disturbing aspect of it is
the accessibility.
Once you,
once you smoke it,
the accessibility of this other
dimensions,
so bizarre,
mean probably even more intense if you
do it in this ancient indigenous
environment,
you're in the jungle and you're freaking
out and South America and he's blowing
smoke on you and you're here in fucking
Jaguars and shit.
I can't wait to try that out sometime.
It's going to be interesting.
You can.
There's places that are doing it now in
California.
There's places that are doing it in the
mountains.
Well,
I might go to the budget and I might go
to the budget route.
Then California.
Well you mean you have to worry about
some things happening everywhere you go.
You know,
especially you go someplace and you have
to trust all these people and you're
getting blasted out of your mind,
but when you think about how many people
are doing it now and you think about how
many bad reports are coming back,
it's fairly fairly low.
With women,
they have to worry more because I know
Amber Lyon,
she had an issue with a guy that was
grabbing her while she was under.
It was a shaman who had to flee the
scene apparently,
but he had done that to other women as
well.
You got to,
if you're a woman,
you have to worry about that kind of
shit about some creepy dude who's doing
weird things to people when they're
under.
Yeah,
and I guess he would have to worry about
that as a dude too.
You know,
if you got the wrong shaman,
you don't.
You don't want to wake
up without a couple of organs.
You know
what's,
you know,
what it is is it's become a popular
thing and when it's become a popular
thing is going to be people that want to
capitalize on that.
There's so much money involved.
These IOWASCA tours,
people are doing them in there.
You know,
every person's spending thousands of
dollars and you're getting,
you know,
20 people at trip and Woohoo,
we're fucking raking it in.
And the CNN documentary,
they were interviewing one of the local
white experts and he was saying,
don't buy this stuff at the marketplaces
because you just don't know what's in
it.
You know,
some,
some person trying to make money off of
you as a tourist.
That's not the authentic experience,
you know?
Yeah.
That definitely can happen,
but the idea that you have to go all the
way to South America for an experience
that should be legal everywhere in the
world is fucking stupid.
It's,
it's mind numbingly stupid.
It makes me angry.
It's so stupid that we have to go to
these countries that have different laws
because on this patch of dirt,
they can lock you up and Iowasca is a
weird gray area too because it's not
totally illegal.
It's not legal,
but it's not illegal,
so you're not extracting it.
If you extract dmt from the same plants
that make Iowasca and you do the
powdered form of it,
which you have to smoke to get into your
bloodstream,
that's illegal.
That's schedule one drug.
See the fact that all the planets but
hold on site,
but all the plants that are there that
comprise Iowasca,
when you mix them together,
they're all legal on their own and
combining them together.
They're still legal,
but the drug that you're actually
drinking is illegal.
So it's a very gray area because they
don't have laws on all the different
plants are so many fucking plants and
it's not exactly an extraction.
It's not like a chemical extraction,
you know,
it's like you're making a stew.
Yeah.
It just strikes me as so disingenuous
how people have to sneak around like
that and deal with the specific,
um,
the,
uh,
the nuances of the law.
Like it just shows you how dishonest the
government is.
It should be like if you're paying your
taxes and you're not staging some kind
of insurrection at a walmart and you're
not a threat to anybody,
you should be left the fuck alone.
And that should include like you should
have access to certain mind expensing,
mind expanding substances.
You will,
you will more now than ever before and
more five years from now than now.
It's on the way.
There's no way you could stop it at this
point in time.
Too many people are talking about the
positive benefits of it.
They're doing stories on CNN about it
and much like marijuana has become
accepted slowly but surely across the
country where I don't care if they do
it,
just keep it away from me.
There's a lot of that going on.
There's a lot of.
Well the let those fucking dopers have
it,
but this way get tax money from it.
I feel about almost everything.
Like,
yeah,
let them do it.
Just keep it away from me.
Like why isn't that the approach to
almost anything that's not harmful?
Well,
it should be.
It's just like it should be legal to
tattoo your face.
You know,
if you really want to put stars over
your forehead,
fuck is supposed to stop you do whatever
you want.
I don't advise it,
but you know when you're talking about
things like marijuana or psychedelics,
Lsd,
there's long history of people that have
stories of the positive benefits of
these experiences,
so deny those from people and to deny it
without any personal experience of those
of those drugs on your own is just
ridiculous because you don't know what
you're making illegal like you,
you.
You're listening to what you listening
to folk stories about a powder that
steers your stole,
steals your soul,
like what do you what?
What?
What's what are you basing this on when
you're basing it on a schedule,
one drug schedule,
one drug that your liver makes a
schedule,
one drug that's made in your lungs,
a schedule,
one drug that's made by your pineal
glands.
All little silly.
Yeah,
come on.
Your body's making drugs.
Schedule One drugs so you can get
arrested for your body makes your body's
a drug dealer.
Your body's a fucking whore with intent
to distribute.
It's dumb and it's only allowed because
it's been allowed for a long time.
If we had to start from scratch today
and make an appraisal over what is
dangerous,
not dangerous for society,
we'd have to have a serious
consideration about prescription drugs
and a serious consideration about
alcohol.
Those are the really big ones we to.
We'd have to really look at the numbers
of people that die every year from
prescription drugs and they're very
problematic there.
Huge.
The amount of people that get addicted
to prescription drugs,
very,
very problematic.
The amount of people that just want
prescription drugs,
they ask for them,
they complain about pains that might not
even be there.
They exaggerate pains.
They might have psychological issues and
these people will legitimate physical
ailments,
but there's a lot of crazy people out
there hopped up on pain pills too and
they're dying.
They're dropping like flies.
Thousands and thousands of them every
year.
You know,
we thought nine slash 11 was a big deal
and you know,
nine slash 11 was awful.
3,000
people died.
It was like 100,000
people die every year from drugs and
alcohol.
It's like alcohol overdoses or like
something around 90,000
I think.
Prescription drugs.
What is the prescription drug deaths?
If you had to guess,
let's just get add tobacco and you go up
by like 400,000,
right?
Oh yeah.
You go up by maybe even as much as half
a million just in North America alone.
Uh,
how many would you think prescription
drug deaths every year.
Let's guess you said $100,000.
I said $100,000
with alcohol.
With alcohol.
I'm going to go with 20,000
just from prescriptions.
Jamie,
what do you think?
If you had to say I was gonna say way
more,
but 100,000
sound does sound like a lot.
So I'll go with 50 to under.
Cut It.
I'm saying it's probably going to be
around $25,000.
Let's see.
Fact Sheet,
prescription drug overdose in the United
States facts sheet each day in the
United States,
114 people die from drug overdoses.
Another 6,748
are treated in emergency and emergency
departments.
That's amazing.
So out of 7,000,
less than 7,000,
6,000,
900,
800 plus people
that overdose.
So only 114 people die everyday though.
Yeah.
That's pretty impressive though.
Good.
Good job.
Doctors versus marijuana.
Zero deaths per day from.
Yes.
Well no one's.
No one's arguing that,
but it's pretty high and that's,
that's 314 people a day.
Three hundred days.
When is that?
In 2000.
Twelve to 22,000
a drug overdose deaths were related to
pharmaceuticals.
Forty 1000 drug overdose deaths over a
total.
So I don't know what that means.
So 22,000
in 2012 were pharmaceutical drugs.
And then there was another,
you know,
slightly less than 20,000.
That was something else.
I don't know who the fuck they were.
A lot of people though,
dude,
it is in 2011.
One point 4 million people had visited
the emergency room for nonmedical use of
pharmaceuticals.
Wow.
So people misusing their actions,
they're freaked out and went to the
emergency room nod,
non medicinal use.
You know,
they,
they borrowed somebody's pills.
Yeah,
we're weird man.
It's weird how much people need to
change their state.
I mean,
even when we're talking about,
you know,
Iowasca being able to help people and
psychedelic drugs,
being able to show people new states of
consciousness and new ways of being,
it's his fucking really weird that human
beings need that,
that we need to alter our perception
like that.
Like what,
what,
what a weird animal.
Like an animal that alters its
perception by what it puts into its
body.
Like it doesn't just exist like say like
a cheetah or a bear or a,
uh,
an eagle now.
Now we exist and we change.
We move her and we think we know how
important consciousness is.
Oh yeah.
We were the only ones that can
communicate.
Like even this conversation I can
confidently say at least on my end would
not be as good without drinking less
coffee.
So,
you know,
I'm,
I'm making use of chemicals right now.
Yeah.
And maybe a little bit.
We love to change.
Our state is,
I mean,
a few animals do in some animals drink
like fermented juices and monkeys get
drunk.
Rent.
Yeah.
They'll find like berries and things
that have been fermented fruits that are
fermented and they'll drink that and
they'll get fucked up.
Yeah.
People,
uh,
people have this weird desire changed
their state,
but the also I think,
you know,
we look at what that is,
Oh,
you're drinking booze.
you're doing this.
But what you're essentially doing when
you're changing your state is you're
using technology.
You're using information that has been
passed on from generation to generation
where people figured out techniques to
do like a pharmacological intervention
on your consciousness.
We figured out a way to combine this
with that.
The way to fucking take the grapes and
you smash them and then you stuff in a
barrel.
You let it sit for six.
You know,
all this was all like concocted.
These are all like solutions to dealing
with the problems of the ego,
the problems of mundane consciousness
and the problems of like getting stuck
in patterns where we knew even just
getting drunk,
getting drunk.
Sometimes we'll reset a pattern and make
you look at things in a better way.
Like you could have like a bad breakup.
You go out with your friends,
you get drunk and you're like,
oh,
I'll be fine.
He crash,
lie in your bed.
It heads fucking spinning your beds or
you wake up in the morning,
you're,
your head's throbbing,
but you had a bit of a change of
perception like you,
you use that shamanic ritual of going
out and getting hammered and doing shots
with your friends to bond and to have an
altered state of perception and altered
state of how you view the world.
Yeah,
I,
uh,
I think people have that all the time.
Like I actually,
I liked the,
uh,
inception aspect of,
of doing,
um,
mind altering substances where if you
can change the way you think about
something,
it actually does.
This sounds a little trippy,
but it changes physical reality because
then you start to act in this new way.
People pick up on it,
they go,
Huh,
this is working out for David Seaman.
Maybe I'll act in this new way and be
less of this kind of person.
It just kind of becomes contagious.
And the example of that that I had
recently was going through a Tsa
checkpoint already extremely high just
to see kind of how I dealt with it.
And first of all,
all of that kind of pressure just fades
away.
So when I was like taking out my wallet,
I was like sorting through my cards and
like just taking my sweet ass time,
you know,
like totally oblivious to the fact that
there's like this machine there that's
trying to keep you,
you know,
just moving forward in everything so
secure and we're,
you know,
we're screening people out.
And what I noticed was that this is
really all just one big ritual.
It's like the Shaman patting you on the
head before you go into the hut,
you're just trying to make people not be
terrified before they enter an airport.
Like you're in the safe zone now.
And once I had that realization that all
of this is fucking theater,
that they're not really trying to
oppress you,
they're just trying to do this thing
very quickly to make people feel like
they've been.
They've been screened.
And Yeah,
there's definitely that.
So it,
for whatever reason,
it made the animosity that I had
retained go away because I saw that like
all of my anger over the inefficiencies
of the surveillance state and that
stuff,
these fucking people asking me to take
off my shoes take off my shoes are just
workers and in fact I can have fun with
them.
We can have a good time,
we can be friendly.
We don't have to be dicks about it.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's unfortunate that we think that we
need something like that.
It
is incredibly wasteful.
It's ridiculous because all of the,
all of the medicine is happening behind
the scenes.
It's intelligence.
They know before you enter that airport,
if you are a threat or not,
at least they should and take off your
belt and take off your shoes.
That does not.
My favorite thing about going through
the TSA is when they break character,
you know,
like you have like a lot of urban folk
working there.
And uh,
there was three of them the other day
and they were like,
sir,
you know,
put,
put your belt into the basket.
Make sure check your phone.
Do you have any keys in your pockets?
Nothing changed.
Okay.
Step up and you know everyone's being
sir ma'am.
And then in the middle of all this,
they,
they break out into.
I told that motherfucker he got no that
shit ain't gonna work over here.
That shit ain't gonna work over here and
you tell him and they're like going back
and forth that Sir sir,
did you take your cell phone off?
Please put it in.
I like.
So they had this brief moment where they
crack.
They will laugh and joking around with
each other,
not just humanity but who they really
are.
And then they go back to this robot
voice and they tell him like,
oh,
you're just regular people that are
working inside this machine and you got
to talk machine talk,
you know,
please take your shoes off.
Put them in the baskets.
If you have a laptop,
take it out of its case.
Put It on a tray by itself.
No liquids.
That's just all part of the ceremony.
They're doing the ceremony for you.
Well they're just safety ceremony.
Their workers,
man.
It's a shit job to a bunch of people who
don't want to be there and listening to
you.
You gotTa fucking tell them what to do.
Check their fucking ID,
make sure they're not wearing a turban
with a bomb under it.
Make make you walk through.
The fifth element.
Body scanner thing I think is pretty
weird.
Yeah.
It is a some sort of a radio wave too,
right?
It's like millimeter wave checking you
for things.
It's just sad when you see like old
people go through it.
You see like some old dude with a
terrible hunch in his back and he's
going to get out of his wheelchair and
shuffle over and stand there.
I watched some lady the other day do it.
I didn't think she was going to be able
to get out of her wheelchair and they
made her walk through that stupid
fucking thing and hold their hands up.
It's like,
do you really think you're dealing with
a terrorist here as this with this is a
terrorist with osteoporosis who could
barely walk?
That's a threat.
It makes me sad when I see a makes me
more sad when I see kids go through it
versus old people because they're
growing up only knowing that stuff.
Yeah,
and the get patted down.
Chefs in the.
I've seen kids get patted down to.
I mean,
I guess the idea is you don't know who
the fucking terrorists are,
but come on.
It's the numbers.
We're dealing with her giant.
You know the,
the numbers when it comes to things
actually happening versus people
actually flying.
My God,
there's a lot of fucking people flying.
Flying is one of the safest,
one of these single safest things you
can do in a lot of ways.
I mean,
it still doesn't feel like it.
You're flying through the fucking really
doesn't.
Did you hear about the lady got kicked
off of a airplane because of her
emotional support pig.
I think I saw that online.
Yeah.
It was flaking out on the plane.
She has a fucking pig.
Crazy ladies flying with a pig and the
pig lost his shit on the plane.
Starts squeaking and squealing and
didn't want to be there.
It was the pigs first flight and so,
uh,
they kicked her off the plane.
No good.
I think if you're bringing something
like that on a plane and it's
distracting people,
fuck off with all this emotional support
animals,
it's so stupid.
There's a restaurant that I go through
in this actress shows up all the time,
which was she brings a fucking dog.
Weather brings the dog to the restaurant
and they have to.
The restaurant has to accept the fact
that this lady's dog is an emotional
support.
Dogs,
dirty,
stupid animals.
I love animals and I love dogs.
I have two dogs.
I love them,
but what you're saying is that dog,
that dog is in a psychiatrist,
shouldn't.
You shouldn't be able to get away with
that loophole.
You know,
the idea that you're so fucked up that
you can't be without your dog while you
eat.
It's hygiene issues that we're bypassing
hygiene issues for one person's
selfishness,
their selfishness and their,
their emotions.
You know,
I don't know what your dog's been
stepping in.
I don't know what.
What's your dogs' butts going to touch
that maybe someone's hands going to
touch.
It's going to mean there's a lot of
weird shit going on when you have like
an open asshole,
you know,
have a dog.
It's sitting on the ground where people
accidentally might drop their fork,
they might not know the next person
might be there and they drop their fork
right where your dogs butthole was
resting on that fucking wood floor and a
little scoop add dog,
asshole,
stupid.
It's and it's selfishness.
It's indicative of a culture of people
that want the rules to bend in their
favor because I need to be with my dog.
Like you can't bring your dog to a
restaurant.
It's like people that get upset when the
whole cigarette smoking thing and bars
get past.
This is bullshit.
When I go to a bar,
I like going to a bar and having a drink
and having a fucking smoke and now I got
to go outside now.
Yeah.
Everybody shouldn't have to smell your
smoke.
You dumb ass.
They shouldn't have to breathe.
Is Stupid air that you've created,
like sucking on some chemical soaked
leaves that poisoned everybody around
you.
Yeah.
That's not cool just because everybody.
Let you do it for so long doesn't mean
it's good.
That's a perfect example of something
where if it didn't exist,
you could never invent it.
Like you could never invent smoking in
bars that didn't exist already.
You couldn't fucking invent that.
That's not you.
People be like,
what?
Everybody else has to smoke it too.
Yeah.
It's a new product and it kills Ya.
So I'm planning on killing him about a
half million people a year.
It's really expensive.
That's taxed heavily.
Smells awful.
Your teeth are going to turn yellow.
Your liver is going to fall out of your
body.
Sorry,
your lungs,
they'll go black.
You won't be able to walk upstairs
anymore,
but you look like a rebel.
You'll look cool as fuck.
Sign me up.
It's just weird.
When I see kids still smoking.
I saw a 14 year old kid the other day
smoking,
trying to look cool.
Just holding a cigarette.
I was like,
you fucking dummy.
How do you not know?
Like you've got to know,
but they don't care.
They just in their desire to look cool
and their desire to be upset.
That's like another thing about smoking
cigarettes.
People love to smoke cigarettes because
it almost justifies their shitty
attitude they love to do is sit back and
look,
I'm willing to fucking suck on this
cigarette and try to calm me down
because we've got to get these fucking
orders filled out.
You know,
like there's this idea that I'm busy,
I'm working,
I don't even care about my body.
Got I got a lot of problems,
Gaga,
last dress.
It's like it reinforces this ridiculous
life.
It's ridiculous.
Life of stress,
this ridiculous life of just trying to
like.
That's so much work to do that be caskey
anxiety.
It's just fucking life.
Just the insane pattern that you're
stuck in getting up in the morning,
having a couple with your cup of coffee,
putting a cigarette in your mouth when
you're running out the door,
light in that bitch up,
driving around,
throwing it out the window.
As you're driving down the highway,
lightened up.
Another one you fuckhead.
That's us.
People goofy as shit.
They get extra work breaks too for
smoking and it becomes an issue.
What do you mean they get extra work
breaks?
I shouldn't say that they get some
workplaces,
they allow people to extra work breaks
if you smoke because they'll become
irritated and become really.
Yeah.
Oh,
and nonsmokers get pissed and that's
crazy.
And restaurants,
it's a big thing because a lot of
servers are smokers.
It's just a lifestyle for a young person
and becomes a huge issue in a lot of
times.
Wow,
that's weird that,
that.
That's weird that employers would sort
of bend to that because if you can hold
it in when you were flying on a flight
from La to New York,
obviously you have to.
How come we can't hold it in while
you're working?
Like obviously you can zoom in for,
you know,
you have to step outside and nobody else
has to carry your load while you're out
there killing yourself slowly,
but you'd be the least favorite bar back
probably at some dive bar.
My con can imagine.
Well,
they probably all do it.
That's the thing about dive bars is
probably a good percentage of people
that are killing themselves slowly
together.
So they're all team effort right there.
Yeah.
They used to be places that violated
California's law.
When they first came out,
there was a few places that were
allowing people to still smoke.
They didn't give a fuck,
but they just got heavy fines and they
eventually gave up the of those smoker
patio still.
Right,
which are just as gross know if you want
to be outside.
In Ohio,
they built rooms and a lot of places
like a permanent tent with heaters and
whatnot.
It just became an extension of their.
They don't have it now.
Their bar suffers.
Makes Sense,
but are you allowed to smoke other
things out there like cigars or a pipe
out there with a fucking show?
Lailey big,
big sherlock pipe.
Pontificate about the universe.
There's A.
There's a steakhouse in New York City.
Keens steakhouse.
You had been there?
Yes.
The largest pipe section of the walls.
Yeah.
What does that put those pipes under the
old pipes from the.
Whenever the late 18 hundreds.
Well don't the pipes like represent
people that came there.
Then they would own their own pipe.
So when like they have a pipe that was
owned by Teddy Roosevelt,
one owned by,
I think Mark Twain,
just always ridiculous.
People would come in,
they would request their pipe,
smoke it at dinner.
I think Einstein had a pipe there.
That's crazy.
See if there's any photos of people
smoking their pipes at that place
because I always wonder like that.
Do they smoke those pipes or those
pipes?
Just like,
you know,
like oh I got brass hat that you like
pinned to the wall.
This is David Seaman's hat.
I think back in the day those fuckers
smoked them because I wonder,
look,
they're all in all.
It used to be men's only.
I was watching it on tv an old days til
like 19.
Oh five or something.
It was a men's club.
Good old days.
Dave go there.
No broad,
big piece of steak.
Can I have a fucking meal and smoke a
pipe the good old days.
But anyway,
a woman sued them,
some actress back in 19 something and
then they opened it up to everybody.
Well,
you know,
didn't they do that recently with that
curves joint?
The women's only gym did a guy when I
joined curves,
I'm pretty sure a guy got upset and
decided,
Bro,
I want to join curves.
I want curves.
I think my hips are too.
No,
I want to learn your exercises.
I want to be a party of Jim.
Be a of curves.
I think,
uh,
it was ruled that you're going to have.
If you can't have a men's only club,
you can't have a women's only club
either,
which is,
that makes sense.
S whatever.
Who gives a fuck?
Why do you want to like bother women?
Like leave him alone.
You don't want to think with women
bothering men.
You don't want to get into get into
politics class and Saturdays plot is,
is you can get in there,
but they have all women's bodies.
They're allowed to have all women's
classes in places,
you know,
because especially when you're dealing
with like exercise,
some women don't want to be fucking
ogled by some shithead behind them while
you're doing downward dog for sure.
You know,
that makes sense.
But my point is why would you want to go
where you're not wanted?
You know,
we're,
we're not talking about like whites only
or blacks only.
We're talking about people that fuck,
okay,
when you're dealing with men and women,
you're dealing with sex and we're
dealing with sex.
People should be allowed to get the fuck
away,
to have like a,
like an area where no one's trying to
fuck you,
you know,
like have like a Freebie,
a base.
Like I'm free here,
like this is safe,
this is a safe base.
Like in like for a man to get upset.
They're like,
women want to have a place where men
aren't allowed to go.
Seems ridiculous.
And for women to get upset,
unless men are plotting women's doom
behind those doors,
like why would you care?
Why do you want to be in that room where
they only wanted to be men?
Why do you want to go in there?
Because they got really good steak and
pipes in the case of keen can't keep
that away from women forever so that,
that they got
to go there before they got to vote
because when did women get the vote?
That's a good point.
I think the teens right?
Like 1915 or something,
someone was to look that one up,
so teens gave in before.
They're more progressive than our
country was about choosing the president
and some ways that steakhouse is more
progressive than any other part of
America.
You don't want,
man.
I've been changing my feeling about
president slightly and now I think I
will only vote for a woman president
because I think women should have a
chance to fuck this thing up to first of
all,
and we should.
We should be able to prove by a woman.
If a woman gets an office and the exact
same things happened,
then we can go,
okay.
No one.
No one really gets a say.
They get in there.
I think we should just run through like,
all right,
we got a black guy,
Elizabeth Warren.
To me,
she seems very intelligent for a woman
and that once we can establish that
they're all corrupt and they all get
corrupted,
that everybody's corrupt or not.
Maybe we'll find out that like it's a
good idea to have a woman run things
because women aren't more.
They're not as inclined start wars,
but we've already gotten the Margaret
Thatcher's and whatnot.
You know,
I think women can get.
She wasn't,
it was,
that's not the same.
It's England's completely different
system.
You know,
it's like,
I think in America there's never been a
prominent political leader other than
Hillary Clinton.
That's a woman and she and she never
really quite reached any level of,
you know,
I mean,
she was never running things,
you know what I mean?
Never.
She was never a governor of a major
state.
She was never a,
you know what I mean?
Like she,
what she did was she married one of the
greatest presidents ever went through
that whole thing and now she has a job
working for the president and would like
to run for president,
whether it's her or Elizabeth Warren or.
My thinking is if every country was run
by checks.
Okay.
How much less war and how much less.
Like how much less imperialism when we
have how much less money grabs,
how much less it will,
all the decisions to like international
shit was all being done by women.
I'm going to go with 25 to 30 percent
less now.
I don't know.
It'd be interesting though.
Seems to make sense.
I mean,
I'm not patronizing.
I'm not bullshitting.
I'm,
I was,
I was really thinking about this the
other day.
I was thinking if you look at the issues
that people have when it comes to
whatever the president does,
so it's always two big ones.
Financial.
That's a big one.
And military.
Those are the,
those are two big issues that people
always have with whatever president has.
And I think that women would be less
likely to cause the military issues.
That's just a thought.
I just think there are less aggressive
by nature.
They're more maternal.
They have this,
uh,
I mean they're,
they're the ones who become mothers.
I mean this,
this idea of conquering is a very male
idea,
don't.
I don't think I'll.
I think the adversarial power thing just
happens.
If you're somebody who likes to rise in
the ranks of power and it might be one
of those things where it doesn't care so
much about your gender may be more,
but we can.
We can test it out.
We can try it out over the next 30 years
and see what happens.
I mean,
obviously I don't think that it should
be only women.
I mean,
I think that would feel if a guy came
along that really made sense,
but nobody makes sense.
Speaking of guy stuff,
I got to use the top.
Yeah.
All these motherfuckers,
ladies and gentlemen,
also known as they'll have weak
bladders.
That's part of why we're doing this
show.
I feed people coffee and I show them the
weaknesses.
I show them that they can hang.
It can't just sit down and talk.
Sometimes I'll wait around after the
show's over.
I'll take pictures with people and then
I'll pay three hours.
Just doesn't seem like a long time.
To me.
That might be the number one flaw of
this show though.
There might be a time in the future
where I decide the best way to do the
commercials is to prerecord them and
then press play and allow the guest to
go and pee because it comes a point in
time where I know these motherfuckers
are squirming.
I start seeing this shit.
I start seeing this sitting up and
lifting back and they're thinking,
man,
do I say it?
No,
don't be a pussy.
Do I say it?
No,
no,
but there's a time.
Speaking of which I have to use the
bathroom.
They always have that moment where
they're like,
I said it and they go run off to the
bathroom.
They have to train their bladder.
They have to train their discipline and
their desire to podcast.
Right now I see a lot of people that are
tapping out early,
no drinking before podcasts.
Just drink.
Just don't be a pussy.
Like I don't understand what's going on
with these people and their bladders.
I mean the kid had one bottle of water
and a cup of coffee and it's fucking
crying over there.
Been maybe he's really just checking
it's bitcoins.
It was in that bathroom and just wants
to find out what the current bit coin
level is.
It's like,
God,
what is it right now?
What is it?
Right.
It gets up in the middle of the night,
has to be checks.
Is bitcoin a bill?
Burr will be here tomorrow.
Bill.
Bill Burr has a,
a new netflix special called,
sorry you feel that way.
It comes out this Friday,
December fifth and he's one of my
favorite standup comedians ever.
And just an awesome guy.
I fucking love him.
He's real estate.
Get theirs.
There's comedians that they become
famous and they become more humble and
more cool.
And that's bill burr.
He's a hard working motherfucker.
He's always writing new shit.
He was on our ice house show last
Wednesday and uh,
he's just one of my favorite comics
period just to one of my favorite dudes.
I just love talking to him and hanging
out with him.
He's just such a regular guy and I that,
that expression like regular guys like
so overused.
But what I like about someone like a
bill burr is that once he's become
famous,
what he's done is just sort of settle
in,
being more comfortable with themselves,
very confident,
but worked extra hard.
He works harder now than ever before.
The guy
is always coming up with new material.
Barack Obama,
right?
That's who we're talking to.
Bill Burr.
You Fuck God Damn David Seaman.
You're weak.
Bladder.
Is it like a little girl's fist?
So your bladder,
Nick.
Little girl.
A little stronger and bigger.
It has a weakness for coffee.
That's what sets it off.
Well,
coffee is a diuretic.
It does run three too much of it's not
good either.
You got to be careful with the coffee
people out there.
They're fucking pound of that.
Apparently.
It's not good for the adrenals when you
drink too much of it.
Today we have a lovely caveman coffee
blend.
Single source.
Quite delicious.
Drinking it black.
No,
no butter today.
I think I might be drink drinking a
little too much.
Butter.
Coffee.
So it's fucking with my voice.
A little accuse me that like coats your
mouth.
Sometimes you're talking and it's like
you're tons wrestling with slime.
The inside of your mouth.
Slime.
Do a warmup exercise before you go out
and perform.
Do you have to do stand standup?
I stretch.
So what I'd like to do to stretch,
to like bend over,
uh,
usually with my back against the wall
and nobody does anything weird and grab
my ankles and pull my head in between my
legs and stretch my entire spine and my
hamstrings.
And it gets a lot of blood flow to the
brain.
That helps you voice?
No,
no,
no.
My mouth.
And I'll stretch my mouth.
I just go up there and talk.
It's not that hard to talk David Seaman.
Not at all.
You don't have to warm up for it.
It's not like I'm going up there and I'm
singing opera.
No.
True.
Warm up a little bit.
I get fired up,
you know,
especially if I have bits and I'm
working on and stuff like that.
I'll get into those bits.
Go.
I always bring a notebook so I have like
a mental warmup to go over the notes.
You got to do that too,
like performing a lot is important,
but just like some of the different
aspects,
you've got to perform a,
you've got to read a lot.
You gotta write a lot.
Like right now I'm in the new new
material phase,
so now I'm trying to expose myself to
weird shit.
That's why I was watching.
I've been watching a lot of
documentaries and I'm just trying to not
even necessarily like actively pursue
new material as much as try to expose
myself to a bunch of things and then
ideas will come and then I sit down and
write and then when I write then more
ideas come.
But like,
I mean this just the open,
open your head up and look around phase,
you know?
Cool.
You see yesterday,
uh,
they launched another other as supposed
to launch another probe to an asteroid.
Another one,
Huh?
This Japanese guy will have dicks all
over his shirt and that'll cause a big
controversy.
A Japanese guy has the NASA guy of the
Nasa Guy who had a,
the sexy women all over his shirt and
women got really upset with that.
It's amazing.
It's funny the things people will get
outraged over and meanwhile it's like
there's a constant churn of people being
slaughtered and parts of the world and
it's like we're going to focus twitter
rage on the NASA engineer.
They're all people that no one wants to
fuck everyone's mad.
That's what it is.
If they're getting stuffed on a regular
basis,
they're not super sad.
They're not getting laid and they have
no,
no weed at their apartment.
So exactly their friends or not that
cool and they're super into their own
gender.
They're really into like their gender
not being exploited.
But if you were a chick though,
seriously have to play devil's advocate
and you know,
you're trying to be taken seriously in
science and you were really serious
about women in science and then here's
the fucking guy who lands a robot on a
comment and he's wearing like hot chicks
haulover shirt.
He didn't like,
what the fuck dude?
Like,
come on man.
You can't just wear a tee shirt that
says nasa on it or something like,
yeah,
I get your friend made.
You sure I get it.
I get it.
I get it,
but you didn't have to wear that,
so I see both sides.
I see.
It's really stupid to get super upset.
I mean there's.
There are ridiculous articles that
completely missed the point.
The fascinating point of this comment
being like the first place we've gotten
a robot to land on,
you know,
and to have this happen in real time
while these people were experiencing it,
watching the monitors and everybody's
going crazy to to to focus instead on
the guy's shirt and did make entire
articles.
All of your focus is on the guy's shirt.
Seems very shortsighted.
Very shortsighted.
That's one of the things the aliens
would skip us over for.
They would just start laughing.
They're like,
these.
They're just so concerned about fucking
like,
look,
this isn't.
The girls on his shirt are sexually
attractive.
They're much more sexually attracted in
the women that are complaining about the
girls shirt.
Huh?
That's one thing.
If you look at all the twitter accounts
of all the women that were really
adamant about the fact this guy was an
asshole for wearing that shirt.
I went to their photos and I looked at
all of them and I'm sure they're nice
people,
but if you saw them in the same outfits
as those women on the shirt,
you would throw up in your mouth there.
They're all people that have given up on
the idea of somebody being attracted to
them physically,
so they're not entourage extras that
what you're telling me they've given up.
They've.
They're into science and they're not
into being slender.
They're not into looking good.
They're into becoming more square shaped
and complaining a lot.
Well,
it's good that they have an outlet for
that.
Anger is hopefully it'll be a more
worthy one in the future than somebody
who's putting probes on a comet.
I wonder if there's ever going to come a
point in time where we have three types
of genders.
We have male,
female in non.
Like if we get to a point where people
get to a stage of life and they just
completely give up on any gender
whatsoever and they assimilate into this
non form.
Like if that becomes an option and like
people start saying,
look,
think about all the problems that sexual
identity causes.
You think about all the mis-gendering
things all the times where you're
supposed to think one way,
but you really think another and it's
very confusing and frustrating.
If you were a non,
you wouldn't have to worry about that.
If more people became nones and recent
survey,
17 percent of America said,
if given the choice to have a completely
nonsexual existence,
they would do it.
They would be really annoying though.
They would be worse,
not worse than the,
uh,
atheists on reddit.
Even like,
Jesus,
these nones,
again,
they would just take up whole
discussion.
Third gender thing already.
Whoa.
A third concept that individuals are
categorized.
I can't read it up there at all.
Neither man nor woman,
as well as the social category president
in those societies who recognized three
or more genders.
Well,
that's an old picture too.
So that means that shit's been going on
for a long time.
Tom NFP lived as a man for many years in
Germany,
was photographed for this book in 1922
sexual intermediate.
Wow,
well you know how you know the son of
man living the hands.
Solaris.
Isn't that hilarious?
Like look at her giant ass head like
that's a dude head and then get down to
those hands.
Oh chickens,
right.
Look at south smaller hands are in
comparison.
That giant Mellon as glasses at some
vintage.
Warby Parker's going on.
Whatever that is.
Non Sex because of no one's fucking you.
Okay.
If you reached that point in time,
you know,
you're like,
you're in your fifties,
you're a scientist.
No one's fucking,
you know,
you're five foot six,
200,
15 pounds below square and just give
given up just so you can still go to
burning man.
Somebody will fuck you,
but you don't maybe know more.
You just don't want it.
Okay,
cool.
Done.
He's just done.
And you can just become a non.
There's benefits because for females
that they,
they reach like a higher level of
physical strength.
They get closer to man,
this is the symbol for non so they can
recognize each other.
The international symbol.
I mean,
we define ourselves by our sex even when
no one wants to fuck you mean that's
your gender essentially.
Like what is it supposed to mean mean
you're a female in the wrong bathroom,
you go to jail,
right?
That's true.
Being loud,
but if you're a transgender,
they're trying to argue that transgender
men should be able to use a men's
bathrooms and transgender women should
be able to use women's bathrooms even
when they were born,
the opposite sex and some people have an
issue with that.
Some people get upset at that.
Yeah.
It's funny how little I think about
things like this.
You know,
if you think about like gender,
like male and female once.
I mean obviously you're,
you can get pregnant,
one can get the other pregnant and once
you pass all that,
once you get to this point,
you're not having sex anymore.
Like you're in your fifties or something
like that.
When you,
when you think about what you are like,
you're thinking about it based on the
fact that you have a vagina or you have
a penis,
but you're no longer interested in
sexual intercourse.
If you no longer,
it doesn't sound like a burden to be
defined by one or the other,
like instead of just being a human,
if you're not fucking see it become a
non.
Then you become a nun.
There we go.
So you take,
what is this on binary?
No,
Google says non binary genders are
gender identities that don't fit within
the accepted binary of male and female
people can feel they are both neither or
something.
See,
but the problem with this is with all
due respect is that this perhaps at
least on some folks is a psychological
issue.
And I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about like literally not
being male or female,
like building being neither being
nonsexual and like if it becomes that
option and they give you an option where
you can walk around and you look like,
like one of those gray aliens.
It doesn't have genitals.
Well I,
I have a couple of friends who are women
and if you start to treat them in a
certain way,
uh,
they're like,
what the fuck is this?
You know,
because they don't really fall into the
female gender assumptions.
Like there's still women and they do
things that women do,
but they don't like to be treated like
anything other than what they are,
which is not very feminine.
Like a couple of my friends.
What do you mean by don't like to be
treated?
There's a way that certain guys act
around the women.
It's kind of like a,
a low level anxiety because you're
seeking out their acceptance because
you're like,
their acceptance means that I'm sexually
attractive.
Right?
So even if they're not going to fuck
you,
you still want them to like you and
laugh at your,
your stuff and like you're trying to
impress them in a way.
But there are women who are like,
no,
like we're friends now.
We're buddies.
Right?
You wouldn't be like this with one of
your friends,
so why would you be like this with me?
And like interject gender into
everything when I'm not doing that.
Well,
they're probably smart.
I mean that is,
it's just that is a real issue with
women and men and it's gross to see when
you're around your friends and then a
girl comes over and you always have that
one dude who like completely changes.
It's about to not as pants and really
interact as a human being.
Yeah.
Changes who he is like this fundamental.
Like the motivation for his
communication changes and we've all been
that person before.
Oh yeah.
It's just a matter of like.
I think it's just genetics.
I think it's neat that a woman is as far
from one of us says you can get while
still being the same species and that's
not at all meant to be a sexist thing.
It's just like if you look at what you
are,
your biology,
your Oregon's a woman is having as much
of a different experience as possible
while still being the same exact species
as you and vice versa.
That's true.
The male experience is different from a
woman's in many ways and so it's this
weird thing where instead of dividing
over it,
we can come together and be.
That's Kinda cool.
You
guys get to do this,
this and this.
We do this and I'm just kind of
intrigued by it.
I'm not intimidated by it.
I think it's cool.
You're different.
You're open mind and you should get
wooden beads.
I should should start doing yoga and
just write this in a book and sell it.
You know?
I think David has that one down.
He's got a couple of,
a couple of million copies that had to
do that guy put some shit up on twitter
every few months and I have to comment
on.
I love him.
It's like just macro trolling.
I can't help him because he writes shit
and it's just,
it's the aware system,
the awareness over and over again.
He's just saying Mumbo jumbo.
Have you ever seen the Deepak Chopra a
sentence generator?
No.
It's so ridiculous.
You just,
you,
you click on it and it randomly spits
out a bunch of metaphysical words,
connected,
you know,
interconnectedness,
quantum in the quantum level and it just
be a console horseshit.
He,
he's like the most ineffective complex
communicator ever and I,
when I told them what's really
hilarious,
a bunch of people were explaining to him
to me what he meant and they're serious.
It's like know what he means is by
awareness like,
Hey,
shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up.
Stop what he means.
You don't know what the fuck he means
first of all,
and you know what I mean?
I mean,
this is a super ineffective way of
communicating.
He knows and you know that that is some
fucking sloppy shit.
That sentence is ridiculous.
It's preposterous.
It's not.
It's not very clear at all what he's
saying.
It is a bunch of fucking Mumbo jumbo.
It is a bunch of word salad.
There's no question about it,
like if you want it to be really clear
as to what you were saying,
but there's part of what goes on with a
lot of these spiritual type thinkers.
People that talk about the quantum level
and all this,
this weird metaphysical Mumbo jumbo talk
is that keeping things mysterious is a
huge part of the hustle.
You have to keep things mysterious.
Simplifying things is the worst thing
you can do when you look at people that
are trying to explain science,
to really try to explain science.
Look at Neil degrasse Tyson's twitter
feed and you'll see a guy who explains
things very clearly.
You never read a Neil degrasse Tyson
tweet and go,
what the fuck did he mean by that?
It's real clear.
What do you mean?
You know why?
Because he's an awesome communicator.
What are you showing up there,
buddy?
What do you,
what do you got here?
Oh,
the chopra thing.
but we can't see that.
I bet.
No,
I'm,
I'm seeing it on the scrambler.
What is he doing?
I don't even know what's happening.
We're talking and there's a video in the
same time.
Um,
I did like one of his books back in the
day though.
The,
a seven spiritual laws of success.
He's got some good ideas.
Quantum physics unfolds into total
acceptance of neural networks.
Oh,
is this one of the generators,
the generator and the Higgs Boson fears
species specific opportunities?
Yeah.
These seem totally real.
They seem totally real,
but that's what he's doing.
I mean,
this is exactly what he's doing.
He's a bunch of shit and some of it,
I mean you can kind of interpret it if
you like,
into some sort of a,
a valid sentence,
but the reality is he's really super
ineffective with how he forms these
sentences and the con,
the thoughts that are being conveyed.
Whereas if you go to Neil degrasse
Tyson's twitter feed,
it's super obvious what he's saying
really obvious and I'm like,
I might say I'm an idiot,
I'm Kinda dumb,
but I'm not dumb enough that I don't
know when you're being a fucking idiot,
you know,
I know what you're doing.
You're just splashing a bunch of words
together and trying to pretend like this
is some deep sentence.
This is poorly thought out shit.
And people gobble it up because they
love it.
They love that.
That whole,
the whole package,
the brown skin,
the Indian background,
the whole deal.
Please Swami,
please Kumaré.
Teach me the way you see that
documentary.
No,
I haven't seen it,
but I know it's unethical.
It was awesome.
It's a great premise.
Go around as a fake.
It's sad though when the people were
like super into him,
you know,
it's sad.
They're crying that he's actually there
with them and you realize he's that he
actually is having this positive effect
on these people because they're so lost.
They're like,
really need him to be that guy.
People really do you know,
want that one person to be so connected.
They don't realize that what you should
be seeking is your own.
Instead of seeking like this one person
who's going to be your guru is going to
show you the way.
Seek your own experiences,
seek your own enlightening moments,
whether it's through yoga,
through meditation,
sensory deprivation tank,
psychedelic study,
whether it's through fucking hiking and
thinking,
just being alone by yourself,
whether it's through writing,
whether it's through exploring ideas,
whatever the fuck it is,
seek your own answers to stuff,
but the idea that you're going to come
across this one master that hasn't
nailed the,
throw that away,
throw that away.
If you meet the Buddha in the road,
kill him.
I mean,
that's,
that's the old expression that said,
throw that shit away.
Like you don't.
Don't want to find a fucking master
because they don't exist.
You're going to get roped into.
You might find people that are
beautiful,
that have an incredible grasp of
reality,
but as soon as they start pushing
themselves as a master run that
somebody's trying to sell you a book,
someone trying to tell you that they get
it.
Watch decoding depok ever see the
fucking documentary his own son made his
son,
made a documentary on him,
clowning him where he catches a
meditating and he's.
He's like,
I'm going to go meditate,
and he catches them snoring.
Videotapes that,
these splices that altogether showing it
and it makes him look so ridiculous.
And to Deepak's credit,
he actually went on opiod anthony with
his son and talked about like,
you know that he's,
you know,
he's just a normal person.
He says who he is and his son made a
documentary about him but his sunrail he
clowned him in this documentary.
I'll have to check that out.
Oh my God.
You have to see it.
You should eat.
At least watch the trailer.
It's just,
it's so ridiculous.
It's his son,
like really clowned him and just makes
you realize like what it must have been
like to grow up with this guy as your
dad,
like spouting his son is very smart to
the sun was on Opie and anthony with
them and you kind of sense first of all
a that he really does love his dad,
his dad,
he knows his dad is not a terrible
person,
but you could sense the sort of
frustration and you know,
the difference between like whose dad
actually is and like this menopausal
misconception that these,
you know,
it's a lot of lost women and older men.
I mean I say menopausal male menopause
as well.
Like there's older people searching,
searching for spirituality that stumble
on the bookstore.
They find work stack of his books.
Yeah,
well I've always been metaphysical at
heart.
You know,
people are always searching for this,
like really deep hidden meaning.
But what's really interesting to me is I
don't see that in psychedelic circles.
One thing that I don't see in
psychedelic circles is the acceptance of
Gurus.
Like that's one of the last places where
I got like deep pockets going to thrive
because,
you know,
when you talked to him about Lsd,
I could achieve these states with my own
mind.
No,
no,
no.
You can't.
You know,
I don't think you can.
And if you can,
if you think you can,
it's most likely because you haven't
been there already.
You know,
if you can achieve dmt without DMT,
with,
you're a better man than most.
Some special creature that's studied
Kundalini Yoga for 10 years and locked
herself in a fucking monastery.
Terence Mckenna,
I believe,
said that LSD was like the most
significant molecule of the 20th
century.
And so,
you know,
you can give that to somebody.
Uh,
if you go on youtube,
you can search for LSD,
housewife,
19 fifties.
Oh yeah,
I remember that.
That's an amazing.
It's an amazing video because this is a
woman who,
if you were told you were about to be
given LSD,
at least you would know it's about to
hit you.
But this is a fucking housewife.
It's just been sent there to do this
experiment and he gives her a glass of
water.
He's like,
here you go,
ma'am.
Here's your Lsd,
and it just hits her and you see this
transformation.
It's like you're as one of my friends
put it.
It's like you're watching the sixties on
unfold.
You're watching the 19 fifties transform
into the sixties to this one woman
through this one woman and her one LSD
experience and a Steve Jobs.
Actually in that biography,
there's,
like I said earlier,
there's a lot of stuff like he called
his era when he grew up,
a magical time because everybody was
under the influence of psychedelics.
Well,
that was the big shift between the
fifties and the sixties without a doubt,
and then the seventies,
the lock it all down.
Well,
that's what happened.
They did.
They pass those sweeping,
the sweeping psychedelics bill,
1970.
That made.
They made a bunch of stuff illegal.
That wasn't even psychologic or it
wasn't even a psychoactive.
Like there's.
There's different compounds that they
made illegal that they don't even affect
the human mind.
They just.
They're just locking everything down so
they're doing stuff without real science
behind it.
They're not going after the dangerous
compounds.
They're just going after anything that
might alter consciousness in a way that
threatens the powers that be,
and that's where they were at.
They were at this,
we're in this weird place where the
world had changed so much in 10 years.
They were terrified as to what the fuck
was coming.
The next 10.
They saw these flower power people and
all this fucking give peace,
a chance,
all that shit.
And they were like,
what is going on here?
This,
this never even existed in the 19
forties when I was growing up.
Here we are in the 19 sixties.
These God damn hippies and walk them
through Kent State trying to stop the
war.
What's really kind of scary to think
about is thinking about how they locked
all that stuff down.
People think it's bad because of the
conditioning.
You know?
It's like you don't want to do acid.
You don't want to do weed.
You don't want to do any of these bad
sounding things that make you seem like
you're kind of on the fringes of
society.
So only the people who are on the
fringes of society start doing these
things and you no longer have the
captains of industry like steve jobs
experimenting with this stuff and as a
result you don't have as much inspiring
change.
You know,
like we've kind of been caught in a Rut
up until very recently until that whole,
the whole like Bitcoin Wiki leaks type
era.
We were in a span of eight or nine years
where it's like very little personal
freedom,
very little dissent or discussion of
what's happening.
They're moving.
So I really think so.
I think after nine slash 11,
pretty much society went,
if it's not for survival,
we're going to put it on the back
burner.
So we were still doing other stuff,
but now finally we're getting that
explosion of creativity and
experimentation that we were supposed to
get probably 10 years ago.
And bitcoin is one of those things and
like real independent media,
like your show is another one and
they're all blossoming.
I think it was all inevitable.
I really do.
I mean,
I think and I think quite honestly more
people are probably doing psychedelic
drugs now than have ever before,
including in the 1970 [inaudible],
the 19 sixties.
I think the numbers are through the
roof.
I think we are caught up in the middle
of it,
so we're not totally aware of what's
going on,
but if you include marijuana and I
definitely do when it comes to eating
marijuana,
I consider eating marijuana a
psychedelic truck.
I really do.
And I think that people who don't,
they probably,
they're just probably not eating the
stuff were eating,
you know,
the shit that you're getting out of
here,
like the gummies,
the inception moments where you just
don't feel the same about something
again
ever again.
Yeah.
Including the very fiber of reality
itself.
These God damn things are so powerful
and the experience is just not the same
as smoking it.
It's way more significant.
It's way deeper and weirder.
It's just,
it's a different truck when you eat it
and it's responsible for a lot of like
ancient Hindu religious art and
religious scriptures.
A lot of that stuff was being done while
they were eating.
Has She?
She.
I mean that was,
that was the,
the preferred method of delivery
cannabis for a long time was eating it.
I think there's,
I think there's a religious high day,
a high day in India where they just
smoke all day long to like get in touch
with the goddess.
One of the goddesses.
Yeah.
I'm sure.
I'm sure there's a lot of religions are
like,
that seeks.
There's certain sex of Sikhs.
They eat this yogurt.
They were explaining it to Duncan and he
was explaining it to me,
so I apologize from fucking something
up.
But there's some yogurt yogurt that has
marijuana in it.
Yeah.
Like the marijuana infused honey or
something like that.
And they mix it in this yogurt and get
fucking.
Yeah.
Blasted.
And these dudes were explaining it to
Duncan,
like how important it is to them.
Sikhs or uh,
an interesting race of people or
religious,
a group.
They get connected to a lot of,
you know,
ignorantly to like Muslims and Islamic
people,
like the people to see things with.
People see things on people's heads and
they thing they're all the same folks
know,
but ancient religions that had their
roots in psychedelics,
there's still a lot of them that are
around are still a lot of them that
exist.
There's a lot of evidence that shows
that it's shaped a lot of thinking way,
way,
way back in the day and if you want to
get on the that mindset,
get into the groove that those people
must have been in when they were doing
that.
If you eat hash and think about what it
must've been like to live 300 years ago,
I mean you pretty much put yourself in a
state of mind where you can kind of
think the way they were thinking a
little bit mean.
You can never erase the information that
you have,
but imagine what it would be like to
live two,
3000 years ago and to be eating hash and
hanging out in India and just tripping
your fucking balls off on this big round
ball.
Spinning around in space.
Illegal.
Yeah.
I mean I think there's more people doing
that now.
There's more people eating marijuana now
than probably ever before.
I think that's pretty safe to say.
The numbers are just staggering.
You know,
the numbers that are,
that are
22 states and the,
uh,
the territory of Guam now have some kind
of legalization,
so really,
or medical marijuana laws,
Washington DC's are going to be a weird
one.
I don't know when that goes into effect,
but that passed recently.
That's going to be weird for sure
because you can have congressional aides
go home for lunch hypothetically.
Get high legally come back.
They'll be tested even if it's still not
federally legal,
which is hilarious because that's where
the federal government's offices are.
So the very state where their offices
are in Washington DC.
Well,
the federal government more than
anything else that likes money and this
is one of the most obvious money grabs.
It's like,
why wouldn't you,
you know,
we're cutting out all of these where the
money goes south to the cartels.
If we can keep all that in the United
States,
that's a fuck load of money.
Yeah.
That's one way of looking at it and not
just that,
but also small business opportunities.
Not a lot of startup costs.
Pretty easy to fucking start your own
small business selling weed.
I'm pretty easy to grow it if people
start transferring that to the,
uh,
using it as a commodity,
like the hamp movement that we were
talking about with clothes and paper and
building materials and all those things
start happening.
If that becomes legal,
it will literally transform this entire
country when people find out how easy it
is for farmers to grow hemp and profit
off of it.
And we're not talking at all about
drugs,
nothing to do with the drug.
Right now.
It's only legal in a couple states to
grow hamp and manufacturer hamp.
And as far as I know,
it's still not like no one's really
going for it.
No big companies are moving in giving it
a shot because it's still federally
illegal,
which is weird because not even
psychoactive.
Let's have a cousin of the psychoactive
strain of marijuana and still illegal.
It's a,
it's going to end.
There's no doubt unless something
happens.
The only thing that could put the genie
back in the bottle,
it would have to be some sort of a
cataclysmic event,
whether it's a,
some nuclear bomb goes off or something
where they have to completely 19,
84.
This motherfucker tighten down the
screws and cut,
cut off the internet,
filter everything.
No more drugs,
no more anything.
I mean they're gonna.
It would have to be something like
really huge,
something really huge and scary and even
then it might not work.
Even then people might be like,
you know what the reason why this
fucking nuclear should happen in the
first place because we were listening to
you assholes.
Yeah.
I think that that's more likely is if
there was some calamity.
A lot of people just feel like we're
going to go do our own thing.
What do you think of all this ferguson
protests?
Do you think that this is just because
of Ferguson just because that decision
or do you think that this is like a sign
that people are ready to start fucking
protesting shit because I'm more
inclined to believe the latter?
I think there's a lot of resentment in
the United States over the fact that for
many of us,
it's hard to find honest work,
but if you decide to go into law
enforcement,
you can suddenly make you a comfortable
$50,000
a year and some places just feeding the
prison system,
innocent people and that sounds like
some kind of tree hugger thing,
but if you look at the math,
that's actually what a lot of these
police departments are doing is sending
poor disadvantaged people.
Most of the minorities into prison for a
owning things that I don't consider it
to be harmful to society.
You know,
I just don't consider marijuana to be
harmful.
And even some of the harder drugs that
people get busted on,
it's like,
well that's.
They're literally their only
opportunity,
but that's not what we're talking about
here.
We're talking about police brutality,
but it has nothing to do with distrust,
I believe is connected to the fact that
they can't trust these police officers
because they can ruin your life if they
want to over something very arbitrary.
So I think that's the backdrop for it.
And then,
I don't know all the specifics of
Ferguson,
but based on what I saw,
that grand jury thing there should a
trial like there are too
many inconsistencies.
The whole point of a public trial is to
figure out what happened and if you're a
police officer and that means somehow
you're treated differently.
That to me doesn't add up.
Well,
I think that when you're dealing with
police brutality,
there's a lot better examples than this
one.
There's a lot of examples.
There are absolutely fucking horrific
that you could find on youtube.
You can find them everyday.
There's some kid that got tasered.
He was in his girlfriend's car.
Cop tasered him hit him in near the
heart.
He felt it's a white kid,
fell face planted,
stopped breathing,
went into cardiac arrest.
They didn't revive him for like three
minutes.
He might have brain damage because this
kid did nothing,
did nothing wrong.
It's just sitting in a car.
And the cop told him,
roll the window down.
Apparently the window didn't roll down.
Cop fucking tasered him.
I mean,
I obviously I wasn't there,
but like they show this kid on the
ground and the complex standing over,
I'm not doing shit.
There's a whole video of it.
How about the guy who was in Denver was
beating the shit out of this guy they
had on the ground because he said he had
a bag in his mouth.
So he's punching him in the face while
he's holding him down.
His pregnant wife comes over to try to
stop them.
They trip his wife,
she falls on the ground.
You're watching this.
You're like,
what?
Then they tried to erase the video,
but the guy that already uploaded it to
the cloud and they released it and
showed it on television and there's a
whole lot of fucking really horrible
shit that cops do.
This is,
this is the homepage of reddit every
day.
It's like you see at least one or two
stories that make your,
make your heart stop and.
But like many things in this life where
you would like things to be completely
black and white,
and the thing that people gravitate
towards turns out to be a massive string
of contradictions.
There's a lot of things wrong with this
case.
The first of all,
the guy,
first of all,
he was young.
He was 18 years old.
Hard to say.
He's responsible for all of his behavior
at 18 years of age.
When you think about what kind of a life
this kids live in,
what kind of an environment he's grown
up in.
But all that said,
he's robbing a store.
Just moments before this video of him
grabbing this guy by the neck.
He's a fucking huge guy.
Reaches into the cop's car,
punches him in the face,
is trying to get the cops gun,
gets shot in the hand at close range.
All this has been proven.
So you're.
You're dealing with a dangerous bad guy
already for sure.
Has that much been proven?
Yes.
So we know that he actually,
we know he robbed that store.
We know he punched the cop.
We know we tried to get the cops gun.
We know the gun discharged,
he shot him in the hand at very close
range.
Well then that if that's the case,
that doesn't strike me as being the best
example,
but it's a bad exam.
Still falls under the range of like,
well,
did you have to end somebody's life or
could you have just tackled him?
Well,
he couldn't tackle them.
First of all,
he was not physically capable of beating
that kid up or hazed.
Well,
you know,
I don't think.
I don't think he had a taser on him,
but I think that was part of his thing
and he couldn't discharge pepper spray
because he was in the car and the guy's
punched him in the face and he was
worried he was gonna lose consciousness
and it's a big fucking kid.
So there's better examples.
I don't know what the fuck happened in
the moments before that guy's life was
taken and there's contradicting stories.
There's people that say that he had his
hands up,
those people that say he was charging,
you know when you have that.
I don't know what the fucking tell you.
I mean,
I don't understand people that claim
they do know.
When you look at the autopsy,
the autopsy statements apparently tend
to tend to exonerate the cop,
the autopsy,
the descriptions of the bullet wounds
are supposedly,
from what I've read,
obviously I'm not a forensic scientist
or anything,
but they seemed to indicate this.
The cop story was a little bit more
kosher that he had a shot on the top of
his head,
which he indicated was charging towards
him,
shot through his arm in a way that you
couldn't possibly do if the guy's arms
are up in the air.
Like everybody's saying,
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
There's people that say they saw him
with his hands up.
Then the other thing that's a real
problem is witness testimony.
People see things that aren't really
there.
One,
one of the women on the grand jury,
the AP story said that,
uh,
she has racist views,
has trouble differentiating between
truth and things.
She is read online,
and this is actually in the AP report.
You're like,
well,
if this is a person,
he's one of your witnesses.
That's pretty flimsy witness right
there.
You know,
there's an interesting radio lab story
this month,
this week rather.
Radio lab is a really interesting
podcast that I listened to and this one
is about a,
I think it was in Mumbai or Kenya,
I forget what part of Africa it was,
but there was a terrorist attack on a
mall and these guys showed up with guns
and they shot a bunch of people and
there was all these different eyewitness
testimonies that were just.
It was hard to figure out who's telling
the truth.
There was 15 gunman.
There was 10 gunman.
Well,
they did a forensic examination of all
of the video footage from all the
surveillance cameras and turns out
there,
four gunman and they were all killed and
these people had these different
descriptions and they like swore they
saw this and they swore they saw that.
But when you go over all the video
footage from all the people entering,
all the people leaving,
all the they.
They have this pretty accurate based on
like real hard evidence.
They've got a 24 hour camera system
going all the time.
They captured all of it and they spent
hours and hours going over all the
events and finding out who's the WHO's
the shooter.
I mean they have a.
They have a grid of the entire place so
they know what happened,
but yet people have all these different
descriptions of young people,
of older people,
people taking off their clothes and
assimilating into society.
They drop their gun and change their
clothes and they they,
they escaped like a normal person and
that became a narrative and there was a
lot of people that believe these
stories,
but when they describe the actual events
that they've captured on video to these
people,
they don't want to it.
They don't want to admit what what is
actually on video you could see
happening.
That's not what I saw.
That's not what I saw,
but it's all right there.
People see things,
especially under stress,
stressful situation,
a murder taking place and attack on a
police officer.
Guns are going off.
Oh my God,
the guy got shot.
Did you see what happened?
I saw it.
He had his hands up.
I saw him too.
He had his hands up and then people
start repeating it,
hands up,
don't shoot like,
okay.
He had his hands up.
I don't know if he had his hands up.
He might've had his hands up,
but to say,
you know,
he didn't have his hands up or to say,
he had his hands up.
It's fucking crazy.
Unless you were there and if you were
there,
man,
I wouldn't have to.
I say I'd have to know.
You need this body camera stuff is going
to solve a lot of problems.
Yeah.
We'll find an honest cop.
That should be the first thing you want
because it means your liabilities now
dropping the close to zero.
If you,
if you take somebody's life and it turns
out it was justified or you use,
you know,
use of force and you need to.
Any jury is going to look at that and
go,
well you're a cop and you're protecting
the public and a story.
No doubt.
And I think ultimately that's going to
be the great response to all this shit.
All these horrible situations,
like the 12 year old kid that was killed
with the fake gun that was just walking
on the street,
the cops pull up within two seconds of
getting out of their car.
This kid's dead.
They get out of the car,
they just start shooting them,
you know,
and the nine one one call says it looks
like he's got a fake gun.
The nine one one call says that.
I mean,
I don't know what the fuck information
gets the actual cops itself,
you know,
the nine slash 11 operator calls the
cops and say,
Hey,
there's a guy with a gun.
I don't know what the fuck was actually
said,
but there's a lot of those situations
and a lot of those situations just
simply wouldn't take place the same way
if everyone was wearing cameras.
They just wouldn't,
they wouldn't.
There'd be accountability.
I mean cameras on cops.
That's like the Internet of law
enforcement,
you know?
That's really what it is.
It's like full accountability,
full access to information and if those
fucking things are streaming,
first of all,
what an amazing show that would be.
He'd build a watch cops lives like all
day long and just stream into officer
Wilson's camera.
The Truman show meets cops like you
think about that.
Like guys in Compton,
like like working the beat in Inglewood,
you know,
at night doing drug law enforcement or
narcotics.
What'll happen is within a few years
you'll be watching it and one of the
cops will take down some meth dealer and
you'll be like,
good job.
The qr code will pop up on the screen.
Everybody will send him like a little
bit of Bitcoin.
That cop will be set for the year and
it'll become this thing where it's like
you want to be a really fair cop because
everybody's watching the streams for fun
and providing tips to the cops that are
not corrupt.
The monetary 10 he'd be right.
I mean this has maybe like a one percent
chance of happening,
but I think it'd be cool.
Well,
one thing that would be cool as you
would know,
like cops that are cool you would know
like who gets people you know,
gives people fair deals and communicates
with people well and doesn't,
doesn't abuse his power.
Well,
I will say like every interaction I've
had with a cop in California has been
positive and I think part of that is it
in the back of my brain.
I'm not like,
oh,
this guy could fuck me over if you
wanted to because I had weed in my car.
Now it's like,
well I'm doing everything that's legal
and he's doing his stuff and like,
cool,
you know,
and you're white and um,
white,
white.
Not at all denying the a racialist white
privilege,
the racial profiling that happens with
cops.
But all I'm saying is living in a state
where I'm not treated like a criminal
for doing things that as an adult I feel
I should be entitled to do that.
Or you know,
in my own,
just an antidepressant basically.
Why shouldn't I be allowed to do that?
The cops here,
we agree it's none of our business and
that to me is a sign of respect,
so I respect them.
Well,
cops in California definitely have a
different take on it,
but it's come a long way.
You know,
I have a buddy of mine is a cop like
years ago would joke around about how he
doesn't care.
Marijuana was still fucking arrest them.
Why?
What's wrong with you?
But they,
you know,
they get into that US versus them
mentality I think.
I don't think we realized how difficult
it is to be a cop.
I think fucking unbelievably hard jobs.
And you're the scum of the earth like
sometimes part of the time.
Yeah.
Well you're,
you're also dealing with incredible
amounts of pressure.
You're dealing with incredible amounts
of,
of violent input.
You're seeing things that you can't
unsee it and you're looking at people in
a completely different way if you work
in a nightclub.
Okay.
Like say if your only interaction with
people's.
You're a bartender and nightclub,
you would think that everybody is a
drunk asshole.
Just maniacs.
You know,
if you're a woman who has to wear like a
short leather skirt and show up at a
fucking honky tonk bar and delivered
drinks,
your opinion of men is going to be based
on drunks that you see at night in the
dark who are grabbing ass,
act like assholes and spilling shit on
themselves and then driving home drunk.
He'd be like,
Oh,
they're disgusting.
But if you were a chick who worked the
front desk at a yoga place,
you might meet like really cool,
peaceful people.
You know.
It's all about the environment that you
find yourself in.
And if you're,
you're in the environment of being a
police officer.
Most of what you're dealing with all day
is people that are breaking the law and
conflict and people running away and
fuck man,
that,
that job is fucking hard.
It's hard.
I mean,
you don't just start punching immigrants
in the face on your first day.
You know,
you don't like tackle a guy and start
punched in the face because you got a
heroin bag in his mouth.
That's like years and years of stress
and and build up and just fucking
craziness had barely keeping it together
and who knows what you're on.
Who knows if you're on antidepressants
or anti this or pro that or adderall.
A lot of them take adderall to try to
stay awake and stay sharp and provigils
a big one.
The cops are taking that new vigil and
pro vigil.
A lot of police officers like that shit
because it keeps them sharp and a lot of
them are on steroids.
Lot of on steroids now.
I don't think they're doing a lot of
tests for steroids and the fucking
police department.
I saw this dude pull this guy over the
other day.
He was Jack,
Jack,
Jack State troopers here.
Don't fuck around so big.
The guy was so jacked.
He was.
He was that level of jacked where you
just don't get there without drugs,
just like arms are like three times as
big as mine.
Giant ass fucking neck.
It was huge.
It was huge and I was like,
this guy is a drug user.
He's a drug user and he's using illegal
drugs and he's pulling people over like
unless he's doing testosterone
replacement therapy and just like,
at the very least he's abusing his
levels.
I mean,
the guy's gigantic.
It's so preposterous.
Leave large.
That's a cop.
Nobody,
nobody has a problem with that big ass
fucking arms and its sleeve.
Nobody has a problem.
That's okay.
That's okay because it got a roach in
your fucking car salesman get out of the
car,
son.
That's what I'm talking about.
Like it's that,
that kind of,
uh,
that uh,
opposition just puts you in a kind of
freaked out mode.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it does.
Even in New York,
which most of us can we consider New
York to be a civilized city.
It's like the cultural capital of the US
in some ways.
If you're black,
the stop and frisk thing,
that's an expensive,
like unpleasant process.
I believe that discontinued that.
I think they will.
Um,
wasn't a ruled unconstitutional.
I don't 100 percent know what the status
of that is.
We'll pull up stop and frisk,
but that went on for years and that was
complete bullshit.
Yeah.
Yeah,
um,
stop and Frisk,
mayor says New York City will settle
suits on stop and frisk.
Hm.
Stop and Frisk.
Appeal is on hold.
Okay.
This is the latest here.
New York City ends,
legal,
defensive stop and Frisk.
So apparently they just.
So they had dropped the appeal.
Okay.
So what it is is apparently there's like
so much,
so many lawsuits and so much bullshit
attached to it that they're probably
doing it for financial reasons.
Well,
that's like California.
We're letting go of the,
uh,
nonviolent drug offenders,
right?
That proposition that passed.
Yeah.
That's the money move to.
That has nothing to do with morality.
It's like we don't have the money to
fucking spend $60,000
for every single person we lock up.
Yeah.
The New York City,
they're,
they're saying mayor Bloomberg's
administration has sought the appeal to
appeal Judge Korea Shin,
the Lynn Lynn's ruling,
which stated that the New York City
Police Department had abused its power,
but a de Blasio is working to settle the
case out of court.
We believe these steps will make
everyone safer.
Blasio told
New York Brooklyn news conference,
this will be one city where everyone
rises together where everyone's rights
are protected.
Okay,
sure.
What that means.
Everyone rises together.
So his cane,
he campaigned,
the new mayor,
mayor de blasio campaigned on a promise
to end the era of stop and Frisk.
Policing.
Yeah,
I mean it's gross.
It's gross in.
Especially if you're a young black guy.
It's horseshit or young.
I mean,
I don't know if women are getting
harassed as much.
They're saying men,
they're saying young African American
and Latino men in specific.
It's horrible to be treated as a
criminal.
You're not doing anything wrong.
Yeah.
That's gross.
Well,
about the guy that was walking there was
just putting his hands in his pockets
and this is a.
that's where we're at.
That's our world.
No judging people based on how many,
how much melanin,
what,
what part of the world your parents
might have immigrated from.
That's part.
That's part of the world.
No,
we have a big part of the country where
you can,
at least in Colorado,
just walk into a gift shop and get what
you need to feel happy and nobody's
gonna racially profile you and fuck up
your life and that's awesome.
You know,
we should have more stuff like that.
But in Colorado that's where that
fucking.
I got beaten up.
Denver Police Department beat the fuck
out of that guy.
What a heroin bag in his mouth,
so they'll just escalating other drugs.
Is that the thing now?
Now it's going to be like,
well,
if you have any of these,
we're really going to come after you,
but this one's okay.
Maybe mean.
What do they do?
If they have drug quotas,
that's the real issue.
Because of a department had quotas on
arrests and some of them do and they're
very controversial.
There's quotas on speeding tickets as
quotas and all sorts of things that cops
are told they have to reach.
I've always wondered what the fuck
happens.
If no one commits a crime,
what happens if we all agree like,
hey everybody,
can we all keep it together for six
months?
Because if everybody can keep it
together for six months and we all make
a pact that no one speeds,
no one litters,
no one does anything.
The cops can arrest you for.
No one breaks a law for six months.
What the fuck did the cops do?
Like what do we do?
Does.
I mean if we can do that for a day,
if we could use just fred day police
departments across the United States
would fucking panic.
We nail arrested as to create new laws.
If you're an oxygen smuggler,
you breathe too much oxygen,
we got to take you down.
Well,
you know what they would likely do?
They'd probably likely get people to
conspire to do something.
They would go undercover and then create
crime and arrest people for agreeing
with them.
Like,
we're going to go rob that bank.
I guarantee you we could make some
money.
Yeah,
man,
you want to rob that bank makes money.
I'm in.
As long as you're show,
we can make some money.
I'm sure we can make some money.
And they set it all up and then the.
All right,
everybody put your hands up.
You're going to rob this bank,
use your fucking idea,
man.
Like that right now is legal and that
right now is how they bust people for
drugs.
They do it all the time.
They bust people for drugs where they
have fake drug deals,
where they put people in jail for
significant amounts of time for drugs
that never existed.
They thought
they were going to buy and sell these
drugs.
They get them on conspiracy to buy and
sell drugs.
They believe they're real drugs,
but the drugs are just a fiction of the
dea is imagination and a big part of the
theater that's been put on.
They do it with terrorism.
That mentally challenged guy that they
arrested a few years back in Dallas was
a perfect example that they gave this
guy a fake bomb.
Set it up,
convinced him that you're gonna,
take this bomb and you're going to
fucking blow this building up and the
name of a law and they got this mentally
challenged guy,
set him up,
got him to do it,
talked him into it,
gave him the fake bomb,
and then when he went to detonate it,
they arrested him.
But to play,
play devil's advocate to play a national
security state advocate and be the
homelands type character.
That kind of person who that dumb or
that easily influenced,
they're going to bounce around and come
up against something ugly at some point.
So yeah,
I mean there's,
there's a fine line with entrapment.
Like I think that they should be doing
some of those undercover sting things
because that's how you find out who is
the bad guy.
And like any normal person would be
like,
no,
I'm good.
I'm not going to take the bombs and go
do the thing.
Right.
That's like,
that's the choice the person makes.
And uh,
that's one of those areas where I think
some of it is going over the line,
but I think they have to do that too.
Well,
I think the idea of the wounded
antelope,
it's better to take them out quickly
before the crocodiles get them at the
waterhole.
There's some merit to that.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Like,
this is a dumb guy whose mind is fertile
for radicalism,
know it's better to get the fake
radicalism than the real thing,
or figure out a way to let this poor
bastard no,
that he's stupid and don't listen to
everybody because they're going to try
to get you to blow up a building and
they gonna lock you in a fucking cage.
I mean that guy right now than a jail
somewhere.
And he probably will remain that chill
for a long fucking time and there's not
a lot of recourse.
And he probably was super excited about
this new thing that he was involved in
because finally his life had some
meaning because without that and without
this spiritual connection to this jihad
that he was about to commit,
like what kind of a connection did he
have to his own existence?
I mean,
he might've been dancing through life
completely aimlessly,
always depressed,
always sad,
and then all of a sudden he's a part of
something exciting,
right?
They call them his brothers and all have
shit already.
Oh,
I mean,
you know,
one thing that I've recognized that I'm
not,
obviously I'm not a religious person,
but one thing that I do recognize when I
watch me and even religions that have no
experience in it all,
like Islamic mosques,
when they're,
they're giving these speeches and
they're talking about the value of Islam
that Islam as the truth and everybody's,
you know,
agreeing and you know,
saying,
you know,
I'll,
I'll walk by.
They're all like yelling it out.
And there's,
there's this feeling of camaraderie
that's very attractive about that.
Even if you know what's bullshit,
even if you know it doesn't make any
sense,
even if it's scientology,
even if it's,
you know,
mormonism,
whenever you got a big group of people
that agree on something and they're all
like,
fucking completely committed to it,
you're like,
oh,
I want to be in with those guys.
Like there's a part of you that wants to
be in that group because there's a lot
of energy in that group.
They're committed to it,
you know,
they're all saying the same old ancient
shit.
Allah walk chanting it together.
Like there's power in that.
You know,
why?
Because Islam is the truth and everybody
claps and you see that,
that,
the draw of that,
like it's,
it's tangible to me.
I'm not joining.
I don't want to join,
but I would be lying if I said that I
didn't see the appeal of the comradery
of any sort of a group that you're
absolutely committed to.
I think there's something really
attractive,
attractive about being the person to
stand back and be like,
wait a second,
this is all fucking shit.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
there's definitely that,
like there's definitely,
that'd be the person in the Middle East
who has,
you know,
twitter on your phone and Google News
and you can see the limitations of being
fed this angry radicalism based on some
stuff that happened a thousand years ago
and use that too.
Yeah,
does that too.
But what I'm saying is the opposite of
that.
What I'm saying is that I see the appeal
of joining these organizations.
We want to be a part of it.
Clam.
Have you seen the most wanted man?
No.
What's that?
It was a Philip Seymour Hoffman,
his last movie,
I just saw it recently.
It was a good,
it was good.
It's like a slow,
realistic version of a homeland episode
so that they're in Hamburg,
Germany and he's this counterterrorism
spy and they're tracking these a Muslim
radicals through Hamburg and trying to
build a case against one of them and so
it really is like you see them more
maybe realistic or maybe less glamorous
side of counterterrorism and it's like,
at least based on this movie,
it's a lot of hanging around mosques and
trying to figure out who the bad guys
are.
Yeah.
I would imagine there's a lot of that if
you're trying to infiltrate,
if you're really trying to become a part
of their movement,
but anyway,
point is it's a really good movie and it
gets you to see like just how fucked it
is that these young guys get into these
mosques and stuff and then become
influenced by charismatic personalities
and can do a lot of damage and it's the
pattern that's been established.
The pattern that's been established was
one of violence,
suicide bombings and you know,
when that pattern becomes established,
that's what people sort of accept.
If that was that existed in
Christianity,
Christianity was overwhelmed with
suicide bombings and you know you and
people really believe they're going to
heaven,
they blew themselves up in a
marketplace.
You'd you'd see similar behavior.
It's a human pattern.
It's when these patterns get
established,
it's very difficult to break them off
and it's.
It's weird how some get established,
but they're not logical like human
patterns can be completely illogical.
Human patterns can involve cutting holes
in your lips and putting plates in them
and stretching them out.
That's a a human pattern that somehow or
another got adopted and the size of the
plate became directly proportionate to
the amount of cows you're worth when you
get married.
That's so unlikely.
If you saw that on paper,
if somebody proposed that as an episode
of a television show,
that there's these people that we run
into and there are a tribe and they have
a plate.
They stick in their lives.
Why would they put a plate?
No Lip?
Well,
because the bigger the plate,
the more cows there'll be worth when
they get married.
The Fuck Outta here.
That's a stupid plot point.
People wouldn't even agree with,
they would say that's a dumb idea for a
show,
but meanwhile that is a very real thing.
I mean,
those people exist.
There's many photos of them.
They knock out their lower teeth,
the plates fit in better.
It's fucking ridiculous.
So patterns don't have to be logical.
They just have to exists and people slip
right into him.
You know the,
we've talked about this before,
but the semen people of New Guinea where
they force young boys to ingest their
semen because it's going to make them
grow stronger and healthier.
They call themselves the semen warriors.
Do they really?
Oh Dude,
it's the most lookup semen warriors of
New Guinea.
It is one of the strangest fucking
places in the world and you're talking
about thousands of people,
thousands of people that do this.
They take the sun from the mom at an
early age and the,
the,
the new male companion,
whatever it is,
starts but fucking them in mouth.
Fuck him.
And that's how they,
they tell them they have to do this in
order for them to grow strong.
I mean,
it's fucking crazy and that's a pattern.
That pattern is just,
it exists and it exists in a strange
place,
but it's there.
They're isolated and you can study them
and people have gone in there and
examine their culture enough that they
write on it and they have in detailed
descriptions from people that have gone
through it.
It's nuts.
That does sound extremely naughty.
It's people are fucking crazy.
David Seaman.
Crazy as fuck.
That's why we got to get people a
upgraded.
Get them on bitcoin.
Do you in this fucking Bitcoin,
you're making me anti bitcoin.
One bitcoin out of your fucking mouth.
That's your solution for everything.
Bitcoin.
Mushrooms in Bitcoin.
That's what you should sell a t shirt
on.
David Seaman.
Dotcom.
Mushrooms in Bitcoin and bitcoin.
Yeah.
Speaking of mushrooms the other day,
the New York Times,
the home page of the New York Times had
an op Ed on mushrooms like very forward
thinking shit,
and millions of people are reading that.
If it's on the New York Times.
Yeah.
Things are changing while they're being
forced to catch up.
The Internet is,
you know,
Johns Hopkins University,
we publish that study many years ago,
the one about people that were taking
psilocybin and had their lives changed
for the better permanently.
There's been Mtma studies that had been
released,
so there's a lot of studies.
It's like they're being forced to.
The were overwhelming amount of
information that's coming out there are
being forced to address it now in
mainstream publications.
The CNN piece Iowasca Sanjay Gupta's
pieces and is complete 180 degree
turnaround on marijuana.
What's weird is when people who are
critics go,
well,
you're not really connecting to some
like global universal mind.
You're just done.
You're just ingesting the substance that
allows the two hemispheres of your mind
to communicate better.
And if I go,
if that's the case,
why aren't I allowed to use that?
Right?
If it's something that's,
it's improving my cognitive ability or
improving my mind's ability to figure,
figure out,
you know,
deep seated challenges,
what's wrong with that?
There's nothing wrong with it.
This isn't.
There's no bodies and people aren't
dying of mushrooms and on top of that,
the people that say you're not doing
this,
you're just doing that.
Unless you have personal experience in,
in like heavy duty,
breakthrough level,
psychedelic experiences.
Unless you have one of those under your
belt,
you really don't know what you're
talking about.
You,
you're,
you're guessing on what it's like and
what it's like is so far beyond the
capabilities of your imagination that
this is a ridiculous conversation.
Is like a blind person trying to
describe to you what the universe looks
like and like you're like,
oh,
okay.
Well that's what it looks like to you
and you can't say you can.
When you get your eyes fixed.
Come to me and I'll explain to you why I
know what blue looks like.
I explained to you with a chicken is
I'll show you what the draft looks like
in real life,
but right now you're just guessing.
Motherfucker can't figure out what a
giraffe looks like with your fingers.
You got to put a lot of data together.
We tried to get a blind man,
draw a picture of a giraffe after you
let them fucking handle this giraffe
fondling and a giraffe Dick and reached
out the draft,
like getting on a fucking step ladder,
reaching all the way up to the top of
the draft patent net like,
okay,
draw a picture of the draft.
That fucking thing is going to look
ridiculous.
Like a Chia pet with a fucking rate
grown out of it.
Sadly,
I'm not going to know what that thing
looks like.
Yeah,
the end.
David Seaman.
We're out of time.
We'll just sit three hours.
This is a lot of fun.
Yeah,
always,
man.
Only we'll only one piss break.
It doesn't seem like three hours.
Yeah,
did it?
You hung in there.
You've probably ready to go again right
now,
aren't you?
I'm good.
You're good.
The power of bit coin is allowing him to
hold his bladder.
Your podcast,
your twitter give people is d underscore
seaman,
s e a,
m,
a n on twitter,
yet your podcast,
David Seaman hour on itunes and David
Seaman.com
for more insight and more bitcoin talk.
Go there David.
Seaman,
always good to talk to your brother.
Always interesting conversations.
We will be back tomorrow with young bill
burr and a lot,
lot more coming up next week.
Lots of.
Lots of good guests.
I'm very excited and you should be too.
Alright if you're not,
I get it.
I understand we've had a lot of these.
This is 582.
God Damn.
All right.
See you soon.
Bye.
Big Kiss
people know and one of the advocates for
it and if I don't let people know how
excited I am,
you're like,
dude,
why didn't you just.
That was your chance to tell people
about bitcoin and I'm like,
I guess.